e
e e
good
morning as the outgoing chair I'm
calling to order the organizational
meeting of the 2025 26 legislative
committee on administrative
rules seeing that we have have a
quorum
um our first order of business in
organizing is to elect a chair who must
be a senator do we are there any
nominations Senator avard motion
Tim I'd be happy to Second all right
moved by Senator avard seconded by
representative Schmidt to have Senator
Lang be the chair are there any any
other
nominations Madam none I believe that um
we have to have a standing member do the
motion and not an alternate for the
chair oh well um you're
right Senor avart is representative
Schmidt will make the motion is there a
second second by Senator um inis thank
you I know the face the name name was
going off in the corner okay are there
any other nominations am I vo all right
only standing
members may vote which is Senators Lang
Enis long and Ward house members myself
represent groa Leon Lynn and Schmidt so
we have nine members present which is a
quorum those in favor I
opposed thank you
the G thank I have the G thank you very
much uh next up is uh I'd accept
nominations for vice chair recognized
representative M I nominate
representative Leon representative L's
been nominated by representative MC is
there a second I'll second by
representative Schmidt there any further
nominations seeing none all those in
favor say I I
allos welcome Erica you're the vice
chair
moving on um we are going to se
representative avard um avard sorry for
Sen all house members are
here moving on uh
consentment
motion there any items remove from the
consent represent
we also need to do the minutes I I'll
get I'll do
that right minutes um any other items
come off to consent
calendar seeing none all those in favor
of the consent calendar say I I I oppose
nay no eyes have it consent calendar is
adopted uh entertain a motion to approve
the minutes move move that move by
representative Lyn is there a second
second by stand on in any changes to the
uh minutes seeing none all those in
favor say I I all opposed nay minutes
are adopted chairman who made the motion
on the uh um consent calendar approval
it was representative Schmidt I believe
it was and seconded by uh
Senator fishing game here in the room
all right on up we're going to take your
I think we moved off consent first
because I understand we have
a just a minor change we want to
make Senator Lang your M microphone is
off sorry your microphone thank you
sorry so we're going to take up
24204 fishing game freshwater fishing
season and
rules you come state your name
one moment yeah hi my name is Diane
Timmons hi everyone welcome um thank you
for welcoming us to make this edit um it
was an oversight on our part that was
brought to our attention and we meant to
remove that given some circumstances
with staff at fishing game it was missed
and so we're hoping to strike the
language um that simply States Beyond
two fish that one of which could be 16
in or larger this is an impact to our
constituents that and it conflicts with
our rules for bass tournaments so we'd
like to strike that simple just that end
piece um everything else is intact but
strike that nend piece so that we don't
have conflicting rules with our Bass
Tournament folks and our Bass
Anglers thank you any questions from the
members I a a motion to conditionally
approve so move it's been moved by
representative Maguire is there a second
second by representative Lynn uh the
motion is to conditionally approve the
uh changes to 204 as presented all those
in favor say I I all oppos n eyes have
it thank you very much thank you so much
for the opportunity moving on to the
regular calendar um first up is 2465
Department of Environmental Services
contaminated
sites so staff has no comments um other
than editorial comments on this one um
there was public testimony submitted and
I think people are here to testify I
would like to clarify that um the
Department of Environmental Services
followed all of the notification
requirements in the register their Ru
making register was dated 41
2024 their hearing date was 523 2024
which is 4 2 days notice above the
statutory 20 days required their comment
period was the typical 5-day period and
ended on 531
2024 um and also there was public
testimony about the fiscal impact
statement being inadequate however the
review of the fiscal impact appeared to
be a review of a fiscal note worksheet
which is for a bill not a rule the
fiscal no the fiscal impact statement
for a rule has different requirements
and the dees and the LBA did not um
violate any of those um so I have no
further comments on
this thank you I have a car is the
agency here wants to
speak on this rule coming up and back
commissioner
good morning Mr chair and uh members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Bob Scott commissioner for the
Department of RL Services I have with me
uh director of the waste management
division Michael whimet uh I'll let him
speak to probably most any questions you
have or or or concerns I I do want to
just
frame the the the the rules a little bit
this is a res the latest Visions are a
result of a statute from the legislature
giving me till till the 1st of November
uh 23 to do ruem and this this is that
and and the context of that is uh
regarding past contamination how it
should be handled uh so soil standards
water contamination that type of thing
that has been probably the agency's
single most
uh effort uh since since I've been uh
commissioner we spent probably more time
on that one issue than anything else and
it's been of great concern not only to
our constituents but to to obviously the
regulated uh industry also uh but
certainly to anybody who has a private
well or drinks water which I think is
everybody so so with that Mike did you
have any
comments sure so um the staff attorneys
have addressed the issues uh raised by
the commenters regarding uh public
notice and uh and the fiscal impact
statement certainly in full agreement
with that there were about four other
items that were brought up by commenters
which I'm at the committee's pleasure
happy to address
briefly okay so uh one of the uh
criticisms that was levied was that um
the definition of responsible parties in
the rules was um somehow um written
incorrectly and became more expansive
than Allowed by Statute but in fact the
rule is written correctly the definition
responsible party clearly identifies
only those entities that are required to
conduct activities pursuant to specific
statutes and the word required in the
rules specifically points to the statute
that establish those requirements so the
rule doesn't change who is responsible
and that is established by the statute
the rule simply established
process uh the second item um was that
it was uh suggested that um the rule
would impermissibly regulate a large
number tens of thousands of past
compounds because the definition of
pasas in the in the rule is Broad and
and that is correct it is Broad but it
does not impose additional requirements
on those particular compounds um we we
received that comment on the initial
proposal we addressed it um past is bro
is a broadly defined term in the statute
and um however there's only four Pas
compounds that we currently regulate by
way of an ambient groundwater quality
standard or a soil remediation standard
and this rule simply proposes new soil
remed ration standards for those four
compounds um but we were also directed
45 h13 um through a bill that was passed
in
20122 directed us and gave us the to do
this rul making and gave us the
authority to require testing for a
broader Suite of past
compounds with the legislature
understood that this is an area of
Regulation that is evolving and that
there are a number of compounds that
we're still trying to learn about and it
wanted us to have the authority to
require testing for those so that we
when we do have more information about
potential health effects we'll be in a
position to know what the occurrence of
these compounds is around the state in
groundwater and soil Etc so the that
directive really necessitates that the
definition of p house be broad so that
we can then and and then in fact in part
614 of the rule we do uh require that
under certain circumstances um testing
for this broader Suite of past compounds
can be required by the department and
then the the next issue that was uh
criticism that was levied was that um
the proposed rules expand the
notification requirement for
notification uh excuse me notification
requirement for violations of ambient
groundwater quality standards and that
that was an excess of statutory
Authority and in fact there's no change
in the language in this proposed rule
from what exists in the in the in the
existing rule currently the text of the
rule that was quoted by the commenter um
left out an internal citation to a sub
paragraph that left uh the reader
thinking that somehow um the agency
would have the authority to decide um at
its will at its discretion who would um
need to make notification of a violation
of an ambient groundwater quality
standard and if you read the the um the
actual quotation in or the the actual
rule it's clear that the the
notification requirements are not being
expanded um and then the lastly uh the
final proposal
there was a a suggestion that the notice
requirements and obligations on
responsible parties um were um were were
expanded impermissibly and the changes
are clearly within the Department's
statutory Authority and are needed to
protect human health um by giving notice
of releases of regulated contaminants to
potentially affected parties um just as
notices currently required for oil
spills so we believe that this is a a
necessary and and subject and
in in line with the statutory Authority
that's been granted to the agency and
lastly there was a comment that the
rules are just simply not in the public
interest and I guess what I'd say these
rules are absolutely in the public
interest they're necessary to protect
Public Health uh releases of regulated
pfast chemicals to soil and groundwater
have impacted thousands of public and
private drinking water wells in New
Hampshire affecting tens of thousands of
residents who rely on those Wells for
Safe Drinking Water um and in fact the
department initiated the rul making as I
mentioned based on a directive from the
legislature to address this issue um the
statute requires the commissioner to
initiate rulemaking on this and we've
done that we've carefully considered and
developed the rulemaking in
consideration of the public comments
that have been received and we recommend
the committee approve the
rules thank you questions from the
members seeing none thank you we have
two speakers that want to speak on this
I believe um and just to be clear this
there's a uh conditional approval so
that's what the motion would be
on uh next up is from rra Young and Pell
the
James and Nat she be from Bia I think is
going to join
him thank you thank you Senator with
your permission I'd like to join him
because it's uh bia's hired wrath to uh
represent us um Nate gray with uh
business and industry Association I'm
joined up here by attorney stous from uh
wrath young and Pik melli uh just very
briefly we have four uh major objections
uh to this uh rule uh first uh we
believe that Dees did not conduct
adequate an adequate fiscal impact in
violation of RSA
541a second we believe the proposed
rules exceed The Authority given to the
department by the legislature by
regulating more than the four statutory
regulated uh past compounds and Chang
the definition of responsible party
third uh we believe there was inadequate
public uh notice provided during the
drafting process and four we believe the
rules are not in the public interest
I'll refer to uh attorney Stein Krauss
for more
information good morning Senator Lang
representative lion and steam members of
The Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules my name is James
steincross I'm an attorney with wrath
young pelli representing the business
and industy Association of New Hampshire
and we'd ask that the committee object
to final proposed rules enbo r600 for
the contamin site management uh on the
basis that the rules are beyond the
authority of the agency not in the
public interest and will have
substantial economic impacts on the
regulated Community um I have submitted
written testimony in more detail would
like to provide a brief summary of the
points raised by uh my colleague n First
DS did not conduct adequate fiscal
impacts uh they did not comply with RSA
541 a13 part 4D or jail car rule
44.1 a 1-5 because they failed excuse me
to undertake a detailed cost benefit
analysis of the impact of the final
propos rules on the state it Citizens
Independent businesses and the regulated
Community given the pervasive nature P
across the state the expansive
responsible parties definition as raised
earlier and the increased reporting
obligations resulting from those
regulations and the definition of
regulated contaminants when D sets the
soil mediation standards as opposed to
the ambient groundwater quality
standards set by Statute the costs are
borne from the regulations not from the
statute therefore the fiscal analysis
failed to consider the substantial
unaccounted for costs resulting from
these
rules second we argue the DS did not
provide adequate public notice to
stakeholders the initial website notice
was issued on May 17th but that was
uh more than a month after it was
published the rules were published on
April 11th and the initial common period
did not give stakeholders adequate
notice and time for these very complex
rules um Bia did ask for a one-month
extension and will granted additional
two weeks by Dees uh second the final
proposed rules also included new
language in EN o 61.0 6D which are new
Provisions not previously included in
Prior drafts and subject to public
comment Bia believes that the rules
exceed statutory Authority for de asked
for four reasons first as addressed
previously the express expansive
definition of responsible parties in
6023 to 34 impermissibly subject
individuals land ordinance business to
liability without legislative Authority
specifically anyone ordered to uh
conduct investigation or remediation
could also fall within parties
undertaking investigation Remediation in
support of their statutory defenses both
under federal and state law or
conducting uh site assessments where
they undertake take a voluntary
investigation but may result in required
sampling and Remediation the definition
of pasas is expanded as to tens of
thousands of past which would
impermissibly be regulated and fails to
include the exemptions and Li
limitations rep in representative eel's
House Bill 1649 recently enacted in
chapter 349 of the acts of 2024
specifically with respect to the
regulated contaminants broad definition
which exceeds the existing requirements
the proposed rules expand the
notification requirements for violations
of the ambient groundwater quality
standards and excessive statutory
Authority by shifting that burden from
the Department onto responsible parties
and that also goes towards the
application of notice requirements for
responsible parties given the broad
Suite of regulated containment is now
subject to immediate
notifications that's referencing 6046
and
6049 finally the Bia believes that the
rules are not in the public interest for
several reasons first the rules as
written cannot be uniform formally
applied because the rules are
technically infeasible to enforce as
implemented given the low past levels
set by table 602 6002 below background
levels across the state impossible to
meet financially by the regulated
Community as a whole and unlikely to be
met or enforced that to serve as an
effective prohibition contrary to 541
a13 part 4C and G call rules
40302 B1 a through C second J car rule
43.0 1 C requires that the that Dees use
that they use broad language when more
specific requirements are needed and
this is evidenced by de's response to
comments indicating that the rules will
be implemented by quote developing
guidance outside of the rulem process
and five separate responses to comments
noted at page 7-8 page 12 page 13 16 and
18 of their
comments finally DS did not adequately
respond to public comments critical of
the substantial economic impacts not
recognized in its fiscal impact
statement contrary to jrco rule 40301 a
1-2 and
4041 B and thank you very much for your
time and I'm happy to answer any
questions you may
have questions from the
committee so I I do have one so I had to
look up that bill that you referenced
which was
1649 and in that bill it uses an
extremely broad definition of pasas
right ites it's not specific and it's s
like you were saying it was specific but
it says uh in the bill the definition of
p means all uh P substances so all all
versions it does but in 1649 uh part 8
there's a revision to the liability and
which defines a p facility is any
facility having uh groundwater or
surface water discharges of 10,000
nanograms per liter or 10,000 parts per
liter whereas the uh solar mediation
standards in existing ambient water
quality standards groundwater quality
standards are lower so that's where we
see a conflict with existing rules with
respect to liability that attaches
through the responsible parties it's so
it's not the uh and the regulated
contaminant ask you for permission for
followup excuse um uh so it's not uh so
your question isn't the the number of
the chemicals that they're doing because
obviously this one the definition of p
pass is so broad um but it's the
standard that they set for and for
trigger but it's it's actually
both
apologize one
second the definition is also Federal
sorry the definition is also Federal
right
sorry yes and as a matter of legislative
intent several amendments were offered
to focus the definition of pasas in that
bill and they were rejected by the
legislature so that the legislative
intent is clearly to include as many
chemicals as
possible I have a
question thank you I have a question for
the administrative rule attorneys it's
my um thought that a cost benefit
analysis is different than fiscal impact
statement so can you make a comment on
what what the how the Co rules address
that so a fiscal impact statement um
primarily compares the existing rule to
the proposed rule um that's mainly what
they're focused on and there's a big
focus on not adding costs to political
subdivisions citizens businesses so it
it's not an a it's not a fiscal note
worksheet that you see with bills where
the agency has gone through and talked
about dollar amounts and how much it's
going to impact or benefit it's it's a
much um TR more truncated fiscal impact
statement and in this case the the
department um did their fiscal impact
request correctly and the LBA gave a a
substantial fiscal impact in in terms of
what we do um if the problem is the
fiscal impact in this case then it's a
problem with our our system and with
what what the LBA is reviewing but as
far as what how the rules work now this
was an adequate fiscal impact thank
you further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you would
the agency like to step up and comment
on anything that was said before
entertain a motion
welcome back commissioner thank
you so if it uh pleases a committee I'll
uh I'll have Mike whims address
this thank you uh members of the
committee so um I guess what I I would
just note is that um with respect to
House Bill 1649 I did not mention it in
my original comments but I I think the
comment or misunderstands the scope and
effect of the specific provisions of
that statute and in fact the statutory
Provisions that are enacted in 1649 are
independently effective we're not
attempting to implement 1649 with this
rul making and I I hope that that helps
provide some clarity and then with
respect to the uh the public notice
issue um we uh met met the certainly the
minimum requirements um but we went
quite beyond that in fact it was
published in the rulemaking register
when required well in advance of the
hearing we also as an additional
assistance posted on our website uh
nearly at the same time and then um the
the May publication on our website was
actually a later courtesy publication on
a different web page just to make sure
we captured additional people that might
be looking at that particular location
but we went above and well above and
beyond the public notice requirements
with respect to that um beyond that I
guess I don't really have too much else
to offer theer questions any questions
for the agency have to follow up see
none thank you so before the committee
is a conditional approval request on on
uh rule
2465 is there a motion so moved I'm
sorry uh moved by representative grot
second second by uh representative Lynn
any further
discussion seeing none all those in
favor of a conditional approval on 2465
signify by saying I I oppose nay the
eyes have
it next up is uh installation Standards
Board uh rule
[Applause]
2469 so these rules um have been expired
since April of
2022 so we thought the committee might
have questions about enforcement
good morning Tina Kelly uh rules
coordinator at the office of
professional licensure and
certification um as far as the rules
were enforced they were not enforced
during that time but for installation
standards the the um RSA 205- D colon 4
was applied for those standards
any questions from the committee
represent Maguire yes thank thank you Mr
chair in uh
70301 it the rule
requires that new manuals for
installation supplied by the
manufacturers go to the
board are you actually
enforcing that rule and are you
enforcing any changes in the uh in the
manuals
not at this
time what they're relying on is under
D4 um it would be the New Hampshire
installation standards as developed
which doesn't apply because they've
expired the design prepared by the
registered professional engineer or
architect for the site that that would
be required because that's in statute
and the manufacturer installation
instructions provided that such
instructions meter exceed New Hampshire
installation standards developed by the
board they would meet or exceeded those
cuz there aren't any
presently right
but my concern is that you're allowing
the manufacturers to make changes to
think to standards that are required by
the regulated Community without anybody
voting on them is that
correct uh rickia medley board counsel
for the inst ation Standards Board um my
understanding is that there are federal
regulations that would uh provide those
standards and the uh board would um then
adopt those standards except that they
Haven for the last two and a half
years and that is why we're doing this
now but the the board is not an elected
body and we can't just accept their the
federal rules without a vote of an
elected body
I I understand that uh the this board
was uh put in place there were Federal
Regulations um that were um put in place
whether the federal government would
Monitor and handle this or whether it be
with the state um and the state decided
to have a board to handle that um but
they do defa to the Federal Regulations
but if you'd like more information that
can be provided well I would excuse
followup I just want to make a statement
that our constitution explicitly forbids
any requirement that is not voted on by
the people or their elected
representatives and this sure looks like
something that has not been voted on by
any representatives of the people so I'm
opposed to
this thank you further questions from
the committee is there a motion so we're
on a final proposal of rule 24 uh
69 all right so we're can stand here and
look at each other all day um uh Doug
want you to tell us what our options are
on this given represented Maguire's uh
concerns about the adoption of federal
standards within a rule without an
elected body
vote um you can move to approve or you
could do a preliminary objection and
have the agency come back with an
explanation um you would if you want to
postpone and take it up in another
meeting you would need a waiver of the
Jael car
deadline have McGuire do you have a
preference I'll move to object I'll
second it's been moved by representative
Maguire seconded by Senator avar to
object to um the final proposal on rule
2469 any further
discussion see none all those in favor
objection say I I I all those oppos n we
have a preliminary
objection next up is uh 24 169 warranty
seal okay so um this proposal um has two
issues to discuss uh the first one is
about the need for some legislation to
address a conflict in the statutes
you'll see that comment on the top of
page one of the proposal uh also page
five of the PDF meeting packet basically
the language of RSA 205 D12 conflicts
with the fee setting authority of the
oplc in RSA
3105 so um basically the board still has
fee setting Authority so um we wanted to
point this out in case anybody wants to
to take up some legislation this next
session the uh second issue is that the
proposal contains expired fees um
expired rules with fees meaning that the
statute doesn't set the fees the rules
do you'll see comments about that on
page two of the proposal or page six of
the PDF meeting packet uh the rules with
the warranty seals fee expired in uh
April of
2022 and the oplc rules that establish
the new fee U those rules were adopted
in August 1st of 2023 so there's roughly
about a year and a half Gap in which
there was presumably no authority to
collect the fee so the committee may
have some questions about the
enforcement of um that particular
section represent Maguire yes thank you
Mr chair I can't speak to the fees but I
believe the installation Standards Board
statutory conflict between their their
laws and the oplc laws is is being
addressed in a bill that I've submitted
this year and if not it will be so we'll
we that will be fixed
legislatively uh any further comment or
question agency want to say anything hi
Tina Kelly uh rules coordinator
coordinator
oplc um as far as the fees go PLC
10223 applies to application and
processing fees and that was adopted on
81 of 2023 PLC
10116 addresses warranty seals and that
was adopted by oplc on 715 of
2022 um approximately three months I did
check with oplc no fees were were
collected during that
time and then it's go ahead I ask any
further questions that was all
anybody i' entertain a motion to approve
the final proposal
the move by representative McGuire
second by representative Schmidt any
further discussion on
2469 seeing none all those in favor say
I I all those oppos nay eyes have it
thank you very much
guys next up is the Department of
Agriculture on rule
2486 uh so the department did submit a
conditional approval request which dealt
with pretty much all the substantive
comments on this particular rules uh
this particular proposal however there
is one informational note remaining that
also applies to the next proposal
20249 um the statute in which the
proposal is making changes to
implement the effective date is unique
in that it will go into effect 90 days
after certification that the animal
records database becomes operation
I then went and looked at the bill to
see if there was any further
clarification and the bill language
itself says that the certification has
to be done by the department to the
Secretary of State and the director of
the office of legislative Services uh I
did reach out to the OLS director
yesterday he is unaware of any
certification coming in from the
Department um he is fairly new to the
position so he was going to ask around
to see if perhaps that was done prior
but as far as I'm aware that
certification has not happened so
therefore the
database hasn't been certified and these
rules therefore really should not be
adopted until the database is certified
and is operational for 90
days great agency
comments good morning uh Patricia Benner
legislative coordinator for the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food Steve Crawford State V New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and food
um that is news to us I my understanding
was that the commissioner had submitted
that letter on October 8th so we will go
back and look and figure that out um
October 8th gave us 90 days to make this
eff of January 6th so
um I had not heard that that was a
question until now so I I'll go back and
confirm that after
this any questions from the
committee so Doug and to be clear clear
um if it is affect if it has been
affected for 90 days then the department
just needs to adopt after after January
6th okay um and I I guess just a point
of clarification just so I'm
understanding the comments in both of
these rules say that it has to have
been
it I I I we read the the statute
differently the statute sh says that use
of the system becomes mandatory 90 days
after it is certified as operational not
after 90 days of being in operation
operational and operating to my mind are
different I think we're we're reading
the statute to mean uh 90 days after the
certification okay and so if you did
that certification in October we just
didn't have like I said we had change
over in in Staffing so we we couldn't
find that information so if that's
already done as long as the rules are
adopted after the 90day which you said
was January 6 then that's
fine okay so um yeah we I'll check with
the commissioner after
this so if I can understand what you
guys are just talking about um we could
approve this however the rule can't take
effect until January 6th correct and and
when the agency adopts they can specify
the the later effective date great okay
is there a mo to approve it's been moved
by sen second by sen the ward any
further discussion all those in favor
say I I I'll oppose n eyes have it thank
very much next up is
2490 uh so this proposal also had a
conditional approval request which dealt
with the majority of the substantive
comments however there were two that
were remaining um the first is on page
two of the conditional approval request
text this has to do with the definition
of reasonable times the agency defines
reasonable times but then includes
additional language that is not
considered defining language uh they
include after the definition which are
subject to unannounced inspection by the
department and accessibility to the
public for return of pets in accordance
with RSA
4376 this is
essentially uh a requirement that is set
in the stat statute the statute
specifically says that lenses have to
allow the department to do unannounced
visits during reasonable times so the
department has defined the term in the
statute appropriately and then
additionally later in the rules it also
talks about the department being able to
go in to inspect records during
reasonable time so it's also later
clarified in the rules so that
additional language in the definition uh
doesn't comply with the manual and it is
also unnecessary
um the second comment is on page 11 of
the conditional approval request text
this comment came from um some public
testimony that we saw in the public
testimony the commenter stated that
behavioral Rehabilitation did not
include basic training and housebreaking
when it came to Foster facilities in the
Department's response they agreed that
that's not considered behavioral
Rehabilitation and that if the commenter
was aware of any instances of foster
facility
applying based on those grounds to let
them know and then they will
investigate um this created an unclear
comment because it seems as though some
in the regulated Community don't
understand exactly what behavioral
Rehabilitation means um and if the
department is then going to go and
enforce the rule based on what they have
represented they believe it means um it
create some
confusion uh additionally it would be an
easy fix the Department could just
simply put in the rule and clarify that
basic house training uh basic training
and housebreaking is not considered
behavioral Rehabilitation um but the
department responded to that comment
from OS that they didn't believe that
including a specific example in such a
broad category was necessary um but
those are the only two comments I have
on this
proposal agcy did you have anything you
want to say or
okay um so regarding the reasonable
times and I
again maybe my misunderstanding of the
process we have been told but I have
been told many many times over the years
that adding statutory language to a rule
is better just Bel and suspenders we did
that here so if it's not appropriate as
a definition then we can take it out as
long as it is still clear to the
regulated community that it it's not
just the the comment we got back I think
was limited to unannounced inspections
by Department employees and uh Council
only referenced the ability to review
records and that's not why that's not
the only reason we're going so we just
wanted to make sure that our regulated
Community understood we can review
records we are doing an inspection
that's what the reasonable times um
includes if the reference and statute is
adequate then that's fine with me that
it's clear to them um regarding
behavioral Rehabilitation
um it seemed reasonable to respond to
the commenter that if you're we agree
please report that to us and we can look
into it the concern that I have I have
developed over close to 20 years of
being a regulator is both in statute and
in
rule regulatory
discretion we we have some regulatory
discretion when we say medical and
behavioral
Rehabilitation we don't go out to punish
first we go out to educate and get
people compliant
first when you start to create lists
that you regulate upon and you create
you add one thing to that list it is
easy for the regulated community that
you're punishing to say well clearly if
the experts thought to add one example
and they didn't include something else
then that that other thing doesn't count
lists are really difficult when you're
regulating if they're not complete they
always create
loopholes if there was a full list in
there that's a reasonable thing I think
but to add one example that this is not
behavioral Rehabilitation we don't we
think creates more confusion rather than
less
represent
Maguire thank you Dr Crawford is
behavioral Rehabilitation defined
anywhere no ma'am not not in not in
detail re Rehabilitation
broadly going
from a state of inadequacy to
Improvement the two things that are most
common
are badly behaved aggressive animals or
very nervous animals putting them into a
home to rehabilitate them to
rehabilitate them to a normal a state
where they would be acceptable house
pets is what we're
thinking thank you you're welcome and so
you agree on the first item of unclear
intent we're okay with striking that
last part of that definition if if if it
doesn't fit in the definition that's
fine again we we have over the years
many many times been told to add the
statutory language to rules to make it
more clear if it's not appropriate as a
definition that's fine and then on the
second item my sorry just had one
comment on that reasonable times um so
it it is part of um what our vendors
look to um to explain reasonable times
that it includes the inspection
unannounced inspections um so just from
you know my other hat hearings examiner
it has come to light that that seems to
be an issue to hang a hat on um so it it
proves helpful to have it um in the
definition just say so I don't again I I
think the issue is I don't necessarily
disagree with you that it belongs in the
rule but I'm just saying it's in the
wrong place under a definition that
doesn't meet our our our general rule of
what defining a definition you can't put
a definition and a requirement in the
same parag definition is definition a
requirement is a requirement so uh
comment by the staff uh yeah and maybe
this will help clarify when it comes to
definitions if there is a statutory
definition you have to use that
statutory definition but this particular
language is not a statutory definition
and if you look at the manual later in
the manual it does specifically say that
when you're doing rules you should be
clarifying statutory language not simply
repeating statutory language so maybe
that's where the confusion is it's not
technically a statutory definition which
is where we do encourage you to use the
statutory
language so we're okay with the first
change we're down to the question of of
unclear or ambiguous language in the
second and the agency is objecting to
the idea of putting uh including but not
limited to type of language to give some
guidance to people who would be subject
to this
rule
correct so what do we say we we can
conditionally we can prove the editorial
comments knowing they didn't put a list
in or included not included we can um or
we going object correct correct you
could object or you could um do an
amended conditional approval which would
Encompass their previous conditional
approval plus the one that was just
agreed
to move second the amended conditional
approval has been approved Is there
further discussion motion by
representative McGuire seconded by
representative
Schmidt all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay guys have it thank you
very much guys thank you
next up is the Public Utilities
Commission on procedural rules rule
I all right so um I there was a
conditional approval request on this one
and I have no further substantive
comments there was also public testimony
some of which was received this morning
so I've not reviewed all of it um high
level the the original testimony was
questioning the Chairman's authority to
write rules um because the chairman has
been giving the authority of
Commissioners in
219 n g n no
G9 and um so as as the the power of a
commission is to promate rules um not
necessarily with the entire commission
but the commission was involved in the
rul making um and so that testimony was
um actually the test the person
testifying was like the problem has been
fixed okay um I don't have any other
comments and I think the agency wants to
request an oral change to some of the
language
great we on
good morning Mr chairman uh my name is
Mark Delano I'm the uh newest
commissioner at the uh New Hampshire
Public Utilities Commission uh with me
today is uh senior adviser Sarah Fuller
uh who will be giving the presentation
on our rules
proposal thank you um and just before we
start and before I forget it's nice to
see you today just as a oral conditional
approval request um for rule
20217 which which is a definition to
position statement um so it now reads
the position statement means a legal
response to a pleading outlining the
respond factual and legal arguments or
viewpoints regarding the same um after
discussion with the Department of energy
yesterday uh it was pointed out to me
that we get position statements from
non-lawyers so we're going to we're
requesting a change of the word legal to
written which was attorney Dexter's
suggestion so it's position statement
means a written response to a pleading
outlining the responder's factual and
legal arguments or viewpoints regarding
the same and I think that would
eliminate um the concern there uh and
make the definition more inclusive so
that is that is the oral conditional uh
request we're making just on that one
definition so I'll start
there um and then just I'm happy to do
this now I'm happy happy to do this um
after we hear from our public testimony
um I have reviewed the public testimony
from uh the Office of Consumer Advocate
joined by The Joint utilities I also
reviewed the one very early this morning
that came in from the Department of
energy um just as a brief background
what I'll say is that uh in July of 21
the Public Utilities Commission was
split and so we have what we are now the
Public Utilities Commission and the
department of energy
um upon the creation of the Department
of energy the commission envisioned that
updates to its procedural and
organizational rules would be
forthcoming the PC the puc uh held some
initial stakeholder meetings in
2022 and then began an ear internal
process of how are we going to develop
these rules to make sense for our
current practice and
procedure
um and out of that those discussions
came our initial
proposal the commission has spent the
last seven months working with our
stakeholders we have gone in my opinion
uh above and beyond any requirements uh
by law to make sure that everybody who
wanted to be heard was heard um we made
multiple changes to the initial proposal
we held two public hearings we extended
the public comment period multiple times
we we reopened the public comment period
after we issued a draft final proposal
uh to allow again our stakeholders to be
involved um commissioner Delano wasn't
there because he was a he wasn't our
commissioner at that point he was our
attorney general but uh chairman Dan
goldner a chairman uh excuse me
commissioner PRD chatt batoy uh sat
through another public Hearing in
October and then after that public
hearing we gave another three weeks for
comments in addition to that um I have
been available to meet with people um I
have spent a lot of time with our
stakeholders so I actually think it's a
great success that the joint utilities
and um the Office of Consumer Advocate
have narrowed down their one issue um I
will say that I have read their
objection and respectfully disagree with
it um they have cited gel car rules that
involve uh not considering our
stakeholders point of view and not
explaining oursel they have cited gel
car rules that talk about um violations
of statutory authority to support their
position and in
the the comment is really simple so it's
a change to how well it's a perceived
change to how the commission reviews
settlements in the course of
litigation uh and when I say
perceived it doesn't
change anything the commission has a
history in the last 10 years of of
receiving settlement agreements
reviewing those in the context of
hearing and then issuing orders there
are some cases we adopt the settlement
as a whole but there are multiple cases
where the settlement has been adopted in
whole or in part um I can give examples
of those if needed um but what we are
trying to do is to codify exactly the
procedure that is in place today the
commission
yes there is RSA 541 a38 which talks
about informal disposition by
settlement but the commission's
authority is granted to it by specific
legislation and we have RSA 3631 17A
which talks about the commission as an
Arbiter which is you know the
commission's job is to regulate
utilities um and to exercise this in a
manner uh that's consistent with our
statute we have uh RSA 3655 that the
commission's responsibility is to
provide independent inquiry we have
36528 um which is actually a provision
that allows us to alter our orders so
let's say a settlement agreement was
approved in full later it comes before
us uh the commission is allowed to alter
its final orders as long as there's
proper notice to the parties and then
there's RSA
3743 which is the extent of our power in
that the Public Utilities Commission and
the department of energy shall have the
general supervision of all Public
Utilities in the plants owned operated
and controlled of I think when combined
these statutes that I've enumerated um
are balanced against how we how we
review settlements and the rules we have
provoke we have presented are fair
they're reasonable they have considered
everybody's interest um I am
uh I don't think that it's uh bounded
that
if if these rules are passed as adopted
that litigation will Skyrocket I don't
think it's founded that you know nobody
will want to settle nothing is going to
change this is exactly what the
commission has been doing for the last
10 years when they review settlements so
that that was in response to the public
comment we received from The Office of
Consumer advocate in the joint utilities
who again I thank very much I've worked
very hard with them uh in the last seven
months to get these rules from initial
proposal to final
proposal I saw the public comment from
the Department of energy this morning um
and although I'm not quite as prepared
to speak to it because of when it was
received I did speak with the Department
uh yesterday um so my initial thoughts
are are these the department of energy
has stated that we were not supposed to
change these rules till
2027 uh under 12p and uh I just find
that to be um inaccurate I think 12p
allows Reliance by the department on
commission rules that have not been
amended or altered but to think that the
commission is going to live with
outdated rules of procedure uh for five
years or six years uh after the
existence of the Department of energy um
is inaccurate and I will also point out
to the fact that the department of
energy has been telling jel car that
their procedural rules are in the works
if you look at
your uh gel car notes starting back uh
and I didn't go all the way back but
starting back in I think the 700s which
are water and sewer which we did
together um in late 2023 there are notes
on those rules that says the department
is working on their rul making for their
procedural rules so I think it's
disingenuous to say they had no intent
to put these rules forward until
2027 when they have been telling you
that they're going to put them forward I
would also say there's a there's a
response to them on their fiscal impact
I don't see how the procedural rules of
the commission is going to change the
fiscal impact of the
department in regards to legal
briefs so the current rule talks about
legal briefs being that that is
requested by the participants the
litigation that was written when the
commission had staff in the litigation
you know the commission used to
participate in their own in their own uh
cases we do not have staff at least for
the year and a half I have been with the
commission what happens with legal
briefs is the Commissioners are on the
bench they need they need further legal
understanding on something the
Commissioners say to the participants we
would like legal briefing on X Y or Z
how much time do you need that is all we
tried to do in this rule was to actually
codify the actual practice the practice
is not that the party is asked to submit
the brief sometimes they could but the
majority of the practice is that we the
commission control our litigation and
what we need to decide it so that is
what we did it is um unrealistic to
think that now because the change in
this rule that we're going to require
legal briefs on every case that that's
not a founded that's not founded it's
where it's going to continue continue to
work exactly the way it is as for um
settlements again I I think that the
change in settlements is is just to
codify what we have done um it's not
going to lead to uh people you know us
not accepting settlements uh as I have
said in many s like different set
settings the commission is a staff of
three
Commissioners three legal senior
advisers two to three technical
experts to think that we are now going
to hear every case uh in full
adjudication is not in what we want to
do it's not in our best interest it is
not what we're planning on doing you
know we have a staff of of a total 11
that's all of our clerical staff that's
everybody the Public Utilities
Commission to get the work done and um
you know the and how we allocate our
resources is up to us and how the
department of energy allocates their
resources up to them but I don't see
that US changing our rules is going to
cost the department of energy nearly you
know
$650,000 which was in there today so I
just would like to reserve some time to
respond after the fact if you have any
additional questions but the public
utility commission's um request today is
that you adopt our conditional uh
approval as I've just amended to that
one um um definition and I appreciate
your time today just had a couple of
comments um again Mark Delano
commissioner of the Public Utilities
Commission uh just a couple of things to
highlight in attorney Fuller's testimony
uh one is um many of the people you're
going to hear from today are former puc
staff that have been either transferred
over to the Department of energy or have
since been uh uh appointed as the
consumer Advocate uh you know these
folks they uh were used to a certain um
way of handling cases when they were at
the Pu and they participated directly in
litigation uh the legislature has since
changed the law on how that's supposed
to work and so you know some of the
things that we have seen in some of the
comments just seem to be a resistance to
that new uh legislative Paradigm where
uh you know our offices to uh you act as
the Arbiter and adjudicator balancing at
the same time the interests of the
industry with those of the rate base uh
the oca's job is to represent the
residential rate payers uh the
department of energy uh represents the
policy interests of the state most of
what we're trying to do with our rules
is to make it clearer how we are
expecting our litigants to participate
in proceedings before our body uh like
any Court uh that requires uh you know
legal briefing from parties when a novel
issue of laws raised uh the puc uh in
the past relied on their staff to inform
them of those things well today we as as
attorney Fuller pointed out uh we only
have a very small number of Staff we
have less than 20 people in the office
meanwhile the department of energy is 93
uh so at the end of the day uh when
we're up there there trying to make uh
decisions uh and novel issues come up uh
we'll going we're going to ask the uh
you know the folks that are appearing
before us to brief them because one of
them has probably brought it up thank
you questions from the committee
representative so just to boil all that
down I'm going to ask a question are you
after has it been decided that the
department of energy is going to be the
investigator and that the Pu is going to
be the
adjudicator and that's why you're
changing the
rules that's a great question um so by
Statute um we're changing the rules
because uh we have to change the rules
uh there's many many instances in our
current rules that refer to things that
are no longer in existence so there were
references to commission staff
proceeding in um dockets there are
references to an executive director so
that's where we started um the statutory
language is often when it's about
investigation it says the Public Utility
Commission and the department of energy
so we both have duties to investigate we
both have duties to regulate um we do
them in a different context but the
statute uh when it was amended back in
2021 very rarely only in the only really
in the section um that's coming to mind
and I could be corrected by probably all
of the professionals sitting behind me
uh but in the area of customer
complaints in that
area there and I think that's
3654 maybe uh in that area the public
utilities uh commission was taken out in
the in a process where was put in place
for the Department of energy to
investigate customer complaints and then
only the the Public Utilities Commission
only gets involved in those on a
strictly adjudicative basis uh after the
department of energy has rendered a
decision if the customer is unhappy with
that decision they can file for a
hearing with us so that is an instance
where the authority is very clear and
who does what there's many other
instances where uh the statutes
reference both of us so I I hope that
answer your question it does thank you
if I could representative Lyn for a
question so can I just follow up on that
so so am I understanding from what
you've said then that there are still a
category of cases in which the Pu is
both the
adjudicator and some element of the Pu
is acting as an advocate before the Pu
no and I and if I and and and if I can
it said that all confusing um I
apologize the Pu is never acting as an
advocate in front of the
Pu the
commiss staff yeah the staff the staff
is never we don't have um you know an
attorney staff member I'm a senior legal
counsel my job is not to to participate
in the hearings on other any any way
except for helping in the adjudication
for answering questions from my
Commissioners um
um the role of how we look at these
adjudications how we participate in
these adjudications is one where the
Commissioners are tasked by legislation
to also regulate they have a duty to um
what is to review
these if there are settlement cases in a
duty of what is just and reasonable and
in the public good so there is an
overarching duty to do
that and so I hopefully I hope that
clears it up if not commissioner Delano
can uh can come in
too I I'd say representative Lynn that
generally speaking uh except for some
statutory uh references to a joint Power
by the department of energy and the Pu
to investigate certain matters uh it's
the department of energy that is in that
investigatory role uh and uh you know we
generally do not uh the best of my
knowledge and again I've been this is my
uh fifth day on the job
[Laughter]
uh uh uh actually actually participate
in those investigations um I do recall
uh attorney Fuller discussing with me
the process for if a customer complaint
comes in and it's heard by energy and
they disagree with it that there may be
a right of appeal to the uh to the the
Pu but um that I wouldn't call that
investigatory
so we can open investigative dockets and
we do it rarely um and I don't think
we've done it since December of
20203 I think was the last one was
closed on specific matters but that is
not an adjudicative docket that is not
that's not participating in an
adjudication in an investigative manner
so that that is how we do
it
representa thank you so I set aside
customer complaints because it seems
that that's clearly defined as to whose
role but others but you did mention that
in some cases the department of energy
and the
Pu investigate do the investigation and
in that case where both of you do the
investigation how is the adjudication
done
I don't think in that case we're we're
um talking investigation in different uh
languages here Department of Energy's
role is one of I think the prosecutor
that's you know their their job in the
hearing is they represent the state's
interest in the policy Wing the
commissioner's responsibility is to ask
questions at hearing and understand what
has been presented to them and to
determine whether what has been
presented is just and reasonable and in
the public good so I don't think that is
in the same vein as that as the
investigation they do not participate
and again if I confused anybody uh I I
apologize um they have an oversight
responsibility they have a regulatory
responsibility but they're not
investigating in in in their in those
cases you know if the if the
Commissioners ask
questions it is it is to
uh provide answers to help clarify to
them what they're being asked to
approve so that that's that is
the you know that that is the
difference representative a or Senator a
sorry Senator works whatever been there
uh thank you for being here uh just I
wrote a note just saying nothing is
going to change and this was in regards
to settlements could you elaborate on
that a little bit more because I got to
be honest with you as chair of energy
I'm a little
confused I said nothing is going to
change and I said it in specific
reference to the comments we've received
on settlements
so the current
rule on
settlements and actually it's um it has
to do with settlements or default orders
and there's another um provision in
there um uses the word result the
commission will review the results of
the settlement um we have changed that
to the commission will review the
provisions of the settlement now that
current rule has been in place I think
since 2015 maybe and in when I received
these responses um we went back and did
some a little bit of research so when I
look at some of our old dockets um which
is well before the split you know we
have we have a
ass uh rate case docket where a
settlement came in in
2017 and the result of that wasn't to
accept the whole settlement you know the
the result the result of that was um
that you know there's a lot of issues
going on um
and where they were going to reject the
they were going to reject the settlement
and in in part or in whole you know the
last one was I think in
for gas
was a settlement where the revenue
requirement was accepted but the terms
on um term of time of use and electronic
electric vehicles and some other things
were called out of that settlement so my
point of is nothing is going to change
because the practice of the PO Utilities
Commission for over 10 years has been to
do this the practice has been we hear
these settlements and we review them and
we review the provisions of the
settlement and we take testimony on
those settlements and sometimes these
cases in these hearings on the
settlements last multiple days now if
the commission were to just say okay we
can only accept or deny the settlement
as whole that is actually going to have
the opposite effect if the commission
doesn't have have the ability to review
the terms of the
settlement and to see if they're just
and reasonable and had to make an up or
down on the whole thing I think you're
actually going to have the opposite
effect which is you know settlements
will be denied
because these five things don't
work and as a these five things
together result in that the result of
the settl m is not just and
reasonable if that the alternative which
is what we've proposed is the provisions
of the settlement if there are
provisions of the settlement that do not
work just as we have done in the last 10
years we issue an order that
says we
approve X Y and Z we adopt X Y and Z
regarding a b and c we find for the
following reasons that they are not just
and reasonable in the public goods
and do not accept that now what can the
settling parties do in that point right
the settling parties all of these
settlements have bullet proof um
language that says if it is not adopted
in
whole uh we won't agree so they could
file a motion to vacate our orders and
come litigate the whole thing that is
absolutely within their right and they
can absolutely do that so when I say
nothing has changed this is what we
do I mean this is and this is what this
is what they have been
doing I have a little follow up with
that real quick Senator Senator maybe I
may I uh a comment additionally to your
original question bring down to
kindergarten yeah this what I'm going to
do so um there seems to be a um a I
guess an initiative or a plan to uh you
know try to uh position things so that
the Pu uh has to accept a settlement by
uh the parties appearing in a rate case
so in other words uh they want to treat
it like they would civil litigation so
let's imagine for a moment that uh
you're you and uh Senator Lang are in a
car accident and uh you know you uh you
think he's you you and Senator Lang says
sir that you're you're at fault and and
uh so so he decides to sue you and so uh
you know uh it's pending before the
spear Court uh if the two of you guys
make a uh settlement agreement between
yourselves on you know the damages and
the liability and you you file that with
the court well your case is over why
because in that case the judge doesn't
have any other responsibility besides
being a a neutral in your
case here the Pu has obligations that uh
you know judges would only have in cases
where perhaps it involves the settlement
involving a minor
and our the way that our statutory
scheme works is that if the utilities
the consumer Advocate Department of
energy all these folks come to us and
they say we've worked it out and here it
is our statutes still require us to
examine that settlement and make sure
that you know it it properly uh balances
the interests of the rate base with the
interests of the regulated utility and
it's in the public good and so uh you
may hear corollaries to oh in civil
litigation this would just go in and
it's over but here we have an obligation
that goes beyond what uh you know per se
a judge would do in a uh settlement uh
situation involving uh you know ordinary
folks did that maybe answer your
question kind of
not so let me add a little bit another
twist to this then so when I heard the
the previous speaker say you know well
you know way back when now we have a new
rule after the split
uh would a piece of legislation clarify
this this whole situation between who
who settles it uh and and because it
it's still sounding very
complicated uh and and uh and I get your
I get what you're saying is Well you
know if uh there there are other
circumstances that you have to look at
even though it is settled get it I get
it uh I'm not sure the public
understands
this to be frank with you so so let me
so let me try and address that point
because I saw some confus faces out
there in the audience as well and there
some of the Prof professionals I'm
looking at their body language and
they're going not sure well and again
you know I may have an imperfect
understanding of what of what their
proposal around settlement is but uh the
way that uh I understand it is that you
know there is a a suggestion out there
that if pu receives a settlement by the
parties pu has to accept that settlement
as is and I think to make the public
understand it is that in a world where
perhaps uh you know the utilities the
the consumer Advocate or Andor the
department of energy do some horse trade
and they come up with something that
they think works for their individual
interests uh as whole it might not be it
still might not be the best thing for
the rate base and our statutory scheme
requires that we make that determination
as the Pu not
allow those parties who are litigant
before us to come up with a settlement
and present it to us and say guys you
got to rubber stamp
this is that maybe is that does that
clear okay
so Mark I I just want to follow up on
this same line of conversation so again
um the problem with the Pu is the public
good comment right the the overall
arching of rate payers State interest
everything else um and so I I think the
concern we're hearing is that the
um the question is whether the
proceeding with six items we've agreed
to these six things and you you pull out
one item go I don't think this is a good
item and yet the parties wouldn't agree
to the agreement without that one item
and what how's that going to break apart
the process and I think whereas before
you looked at the when you were saying
the results based right all the results
of this good for everybody versus every
single individual lying being good for
everybody um and I can you address that
at all I I think that's the concern I I
heard when and people were talking about
was this line by line veto power
basically um that allows you to strike
up a vision which would totally make a
an agency or or an individual say never
mind I don't want to do that if you
strike that that breaks the whole deal
so how does that so to be clear we're
not talking about a line item veto kind
of situation I think I think what we're
what we're contemplating is that if if
we got that settlement agreement with
six items and we found that with all six
of those items it's the the agreement is
problematic based on the standards that
we need to evaluate it under we can go
back to the parties and say you know
what we're good with the first five the
six one we've got a problem with can you
renegotiate it can you work on it can
you can you come back to us with
something that's more feasible those are
the kinds of uh you know this the kinds
of things that happened in the past um
and ultimately we want the parties to be
able to settle it in a way that allows
the Pu to approve it but that doesn't
always happen and when that doesn't
happen we need to have the flexibility
to you know instruct the parties on what
aspects we have problems with versus a
just saying not it's denied let's
litigate the case and and maybe that is
that does that answer your question
right anything else from anything to add
to
that no just my only my only add to that
is just that the the objection is based
on that this doesn't follow
a38 so the objection is is that that
this small provision in one of a you
know this one rule in a 50-page rule set
violates 541 838 and that's the informal
settlement provision and that if you
look at our rules as a
whole uh there are multiple places where
we do provide uh settlement instructions
we have a whole prehearing process on it
we that is built every procedural
schedule has settlement built into it
and I do not think
that we are at all close to violating
541 838 given the fact that we have
provided for settlements we engage in
settlements we encourage settlements and
then when you balance that with our own
statutes which have to take priority as
to how we look at these settlements I
just I want to put it back in that that
context like what are what is the
objection the objection is we are
violating the administrative procedures
act and and and we are not violating the
administrative procedures act you know
we we have a duty to look at these
settlements we have a duty to not just
sign these settlements and you know that
that's really just want I want to just
bring it back to what is the objection
and how and how have we responded so you
know I really appreciate all these
questions and I'll tell you I've worked
with these parties behind me that might
be making faces right now um for the
last seven months and it's in I don't
often get to engage with my stakeholders
that much given my role with the
commission it's been um enjoyable it has
been sometimes frustrating uh and for
the most part we've really worked very
hard um I think they would all tell you
that uh there are multiple multiple
multiple Provisions in our conditional
approval request that they authored
that they suggested that they put
forward we have
removed multiple things because that is
what they asked us to do so if and if
you compared the initial and you
compared the conditional you would see
that um and you know in my opinion this
final conditional approval is very much
um a reasonable compromise and that
there's no violations you know I there
you're there there is no violations we
have it's not that our public
stakeholders you know we have to adopt
everything they say we have to you know
by Jael car rule we have to listen and
we have to explain and I think we have
listened and we have explained thank you
thank you so we have three more speakers
on this still so next up is the
Department of
energy uh Marie and Paul
chairman if I could jump in for a second
I um just wanted to address uh rul
making by the department of energy they
have uh put forward um some procedure of
rules however there's only one section
in that proposal and that's the waiver
of rule section so other words their
General requirements for procedures they
don't have anything so the only thing
they put forward is the waiver of rules
and my understanding is that was the
primary rule set that they were relying
on for um the Pu rule they were mostly
relying on the waiver rules
section good morning Madame chair
members of the
committee want to make a few um
introductory remarks um and I'm going to
find the notes that I mean to rely
on guys have you guys introduce yourself
for the record of make sure we have it
my name is Marie Helen Balon and I am an
attorney with the New Hampshire
Department of energy
and uh good morning my name is Paul
Dexter I'm the legal director at the New
Hampshire Department of
energy um to start off with I want to
explain briefly our um partip IP ation
in pu's um Ru making 200 uh Ru making
process before I get to the few
remaining concerns that we want to share
with the committee the concerns are
outlined in the letter we provided to
the committee
yesterday this has been an arduous
process and it feels like no stone has
gone
unturned we are thankful to the Pu for
considering comments received um
addressing the many concerns um the
department raised following each version
of the rules and making changes
throughout these past 7
months there have been two public
comment hearings and the department
appeared at and um which the department
appeared at and Then followed up with
lengthy written
comments the department prioritizes
commentary between sister agencies and
balances that with uh reviewing the
processes and procedures that affect the
Department's particip
ipation in proceedings before the
Pu upon review of the conditional
approval request um the department notes
uh a few significant changes that are a
departure from the current rules and
that could have cost
implications um as as was just discussed
um prior the Office of Consumer Advocate
and the joint utilities
have shared a letter filed with gelgar
that discusses one of the points that we
made in our letter the changes discussed
in that letter um relate to pu 20410 B
um specifically The pu's Proposal
requires the Pu to determine that each
provision of a settlement agreement
meets the statutory requirements um and
that replaces the requirement that pu
determin that the result of a settlement
agreement meets those
requirements the department
independently from the OCA and and
Public Utilities analyzed this um as
problematic and agrees with OCA and the
joint utilities that the pu's proposal
conflicts with the principles of RSA 541
a38 that the proposal would impede
settlements cause the department to have
to prepare for hearing to defend
provisions and in so doing create cause
costs the department has analyzed that
fewer settlements would require an
additional analyst um in each of the
regulatory
divisions for each division in its
regulatory section comprising water
electric and gas the department foresees
um the need for up to one additional
staff person as well as up two two
additional Attorneys at an estimated
total annual cost of up to $675,000
if this change together with the changes
to the brief section um I'll discuss
next is
enacted um relative to the requirement
of briefs um at pu uh 20419 rather than
the allowance of briefs the Pu could
essentially order a legal brief in each
proceeding if it goes that far there are
cost implications as analyzed by the
department the department recommends
that the language of the underlying
rules um in those sections be
maintained there is no reason to change
language that historically has
worked other items raised in our letter
pertain to the revision to the
definition of position statement at pu
20217 which attorney Fuller stated was
going to be um amended in an amended um
conditional approval request um and a
change at 203 um 18 regarding the
identification by the commission
um by commission um of uh the commission
information requests responses to be
relied on in final decisions or their
reasoning so that parties have an
opportunity to bolster or rebut those
facts um and that's all we have uh for
um opening comments happy to take
questions thank you thank you questions
from the
committee representative ly thank you so
you know I'm I guess I'm a little bit um
concerned because it seems like we have
two agencies of the executive branch of
government that aren't able to agree on
what a rule should be and I guess what
I'm the thing that I'm troubled by is
you now are asking this Committee of the
legislature to resolve
that it and that seems to me that's much
different than where you know the PRI a
private party have asking the
legislature to resolve something if they
have a dispute with proposed regulations
by by um an administrative agency so the
thing I'm I guess I'm concerned about is
why
haven't why hasn't the department of
energy and the Public Utilities
Commission gone and sat down with
somebody at the Attorney General's
office for example and come up with the
the executive Branch's position on this
instead we have you know this arm of the
executive branch says hey and this arm
of the executive branch says b and you
want us to resolve it my
inclination personally I don't know what
my college would say would be to say
listen you guys in the executive branch
Work It Out Among yourselves and when
you do come to us and and will then hear
from the public and if there's and we'll
make a decision but why should we
resolve the executive Branch's
dispute SM just to say that yes we've
we've reached an impass we want to um
provide the information to the committee
um that's uh we we've worked um on these
rules for seven months and this this is
an impass uh we want to give the
information to the committee and that's
why we're here
today that's the point I wanted to make
is that our purpose today is to point
out that we have raised concerns with
these two particular settlements that we
believe will have uh an effect on the
workload that the Department of energy
has to do and therefore the Personnel
that'll be needed to do that workload we
wanted to quantify that for the
commission today which we've done for
the committee today which we've done um
and uh you know I would go back to what
attorney Fuller said from the from the
Pu uh we have worked hard uh with uh the
Pu to go from uh a rule set that was
proposed seven months ago to uh
basically have focused in on these two
issues and where the the reason we're
focusing on those two issues today is
because of the potential for the
additional workload and
resources I'm going to follow up the
question so again so the two issues you
have are the change from results to
Provisions is that that's the first one
we're arguing about yes all right and
the second one is around the brief
section I I want to ask a question
around the brief section yes that's
correct okay so
20419 says the commission shall require
parties to submit briefs at any point in
the proceeding if the commission
determines that such briefing would
assist the Commissioners in determining
uh determination of the legal issues
being
presented and you object to that you
don't think they should be able to allow
if you're presenting a legal point they
should be able to ask you to clarify or
expand and give them a brief on that
issue no not at all uh I think the
the the we're here to point out that if
the if that rule is adopted that there
will be a need for for additional
resources at the department uh we can't
predict uh right now we under the
existing rule where the parties that
appear before the commission can request
uh the authority to submit briefs we
have some control over that uh and it's
in practice it's done infrequently a
small percentage of the cases that go
before the commission result in in in
briefing um if the commission requires
legal briefs in a lot of proceedings or
all proceedings or all the big
proceedings there's going to be a
significant shift in the workload that
the Department's going to have to do
that's our primary point I don't
question that the department sorry that
the commission has the authority to do
that under their statutes obviously they
get to run the hearings the way they
like but we just want to point out the
fact that there's going to be a s
potential for a significant impact uh if
uh the commission is now enshrine that
Authority in their rules and uses the
authority uh I I did this type of work
in Massachusetts for years and it's not
uncommon to see briefs at the end of
cases multiple hundreds of pages issue
by issue item by item and it's an
expensive process what happens before
the Public Utility Commission in New
Hampshire currently is in most instances
A party's closing arguments are done
orally before the commission uh there's
obviously some prep time involved but
those closing arguments Run 10 to 15
minutes sometimes in a very complicated
case might go 30 to 60 minutes that's an
entire different situation than reducing
all those arguments to a legal brief uh
it's just a a different level of
workload
okay just just real quickly uh so would
would I be out of line by saying if we
adopt these rules as is that they would
it's just adding another layer of
bureaucracy to these
settlements to the settlement no the I
was talking about briefs settlement is a
different issue um and I don't think I
would characterize it as that our
position on the um on the issue of
settlement is changing the way uh
parties prepare a settlement and the way
the commission views the settlement and
and I think we went through that before
results versus Provisions so I won't
repeat all that
now any further
questions thank you sir would like the
language of the changed role that we're
talking about in terms of the
settlement because I have the old role
the current role and the proposed role
it's okay
okay uh thank you guys we're going to
bring up next um Jessica from eversource
oh and I guess Don's going to join him
which means I got two speakers knocked
out of the way yes Mr chairman I was
hoping that you would grant me and M
kavara leave to appear jointly and I'm
thinking that's going to help move this
along um let me start by introducing
myself and then miss kavara can
introduce herself my name is Donald Cree
I am the consumer Advocate I've served
in that post since early
2016 my job pursuing to RSA 363 3 28 is
to represent the interests of the
state's residential utility customers
and uh Miss
kavara thank you Don uh good morning
committee uh Jessica Kar I represent
Public Service Company of New Hampshire
that does business as eversource energy
and uh obviously the utilities filed
joint comments with the office of the
consumer Advocate on the issue of
settlements so oh I'm sorry to interrupt
I I just wanted to point out to the
committee what an extraordinary
Confluence this is it's not the consumer
Advocate and the state's utilities agree
more than you might think but we are
typically adversaries before the Public
Utilities Commission and so it is a bit
noteworthy that we're here uh jointly
appearing before the Jael card and I
just want you to take note of that I I
also want to thank the Pu uh Miss Fuller
gave you a lengthy recitation of all the
efforts that that agency is undertaken
over the last few months to hear the
concerns of parties and I know they've
heard the concerns of my office we
submitted I don't know something like 40
pages of comments on their initial
proposal back in the summer and we've
boiled those concerns down to the one
issue in the letter that we filed with
the joint utilities that that's a big
deal and as Miss Fuller explained to you
uh a lot of the concerns that the
parties and certainly a lot of the
concerns that I interposed have been
adequately addressed addressed in the
final proposal uh that has before you
and I I know because I've heard from
others that Miss Fuller reached out to
the utilities and to the department
affirmatively over the last two weeks
that there's been a lot of contact
amongst that group of stakeholders and I
I know those stakeholders are are
grateful for that I I also want to say
that I was a little disappointed to hear
hints of disregard for the experience of
those of us who have practiced before or
been employed by the Public Utilities
Commission over the years I first went
to work for the puc in 1999 I worked
there for 9 years the last time the
puc's procedural rules were
comprehensively revised was 2007 and I
was the general counsel of the agency so
I had the job of representing the agency
before this body and we had similar
conversations then then in
2021 via House Bill 2 the Budget Trailer
Bill the department of energy was
created sort of CED off from the Pu and
I I was a big supporter of that
initiative one of the reasons that I was
a big supporter of that initiative is
that it was openly acknowledged at the
time that doing that changing state
government to that degree was a big deal
that was being accomplished imperfectly
via the trailer bill and the expectation
was that through processes like this one
we would work through some of the
details that left that were left on
resolved at that time and so in a sense
that's what we're uh busy doing here
resolving those imperfections frankly
some of those imperfections and this
goes to questions from Senator avard and
representative Lynn some of those
questions are going to have to be
resolved by legislation uh I I concluded
and I think other parties did too that
what the what the Pu is proposing here
reflect colorable interpretations of
their enabling legislation as it's been
revised and so to the extent further
revision is required it isn't fair to
ask you to deal with that we're going to
go and ask the uh subject matter
Committees of the legislature to deal
with those questions um I I also want to
say as the consumer Advocate that I am
particularly concerned about things that
drive up the cost of having utility
regulation in this state and there's a
pretty straightforward reason why that
is every last cent of the cost of
utility regulation in New Hampshire is
taxed taxed to the state's rate payers
so when the process becomes needlessly
complicated or difficult or challenging
rate payers pay we're we're the only
wallet in the room as I'm I'm fond of
saying so given all of that we've boiled
our concerns down to this one provision
of the rules that has to do with the way
the puc handles
settlements and I I guess what I want to
have what I want to say about that is
that if if in in fact nothing is
changing about the
pu's method for dealing with settlements
that are presented to it then I don't
understand and I don't think you should
understand why the Pu needs to change
the language of its rule um I I think
what the Pu is trying to do here is
codifying a existing practice or a habit
that has crept up in recent years which
is to pick a heart settlements to a
degree that it has not before now I do
not suggest to you that the Pu doesn't
have its own independent authority to
take a look at settlement agreements
that are presented to it and not simply
do what the Superior Court would do uh
in in in approving a settlement of a
routine uh bit of civil litigation the
Pu does have overarching authority to
assess settlement agreements to make
sure that they're lawful and serve the
public interest but what isn't helpful
is when the Pu goes line by line or
provision by provision from settlement
agreements and Cherry picks them even
worse is when the Pu simply ignores
settlement agreements which is exactly
what they did back in mid November when
they decided the big uh net metering
case stock at
22060 that is pending before the
commission so that is the issue that we
are raising here with you today now miss
kavara can address this on on behalf of
the utilities from my perspective as
consumer Advocate I can't enter into
settlement agreements anymore because I
have no Assurance representative Lynn
will appreciate this when an attorney
sits down to negotiate a settlement
agreement she or he does that by
assessing litigation risk you know how
does my proposed resolution of this case
compare with what I think the tribunal's
likely resolution of the case is going
to be when I can't do that assessment
because I think the tribunal is going to
just pick apart every little provision
of the settlement agreement then I can't
assess the litigation risk I can't sign
settlement agreements and therefore I
have to bring every single issue on a
contested basis before the tribunal
that's the situation I find myself in
right now as consumer Advocate that's
why from my perspective I think that the
objection we have interposed is um a
reasonable one that you should take very
seriously I just want to make one little
comment about something that isn't in
our letter and it has to do with the
issue the department has raised which
has to do with briefs um I I learned in
law school that litigation whether it
happens in court or before an
administrative tribunal is an attorney
driven process in that it's my job as an
attorney representing a client before
the Pu or before a court to decide how
and what I want to say to the Tribunal
by way of legal argument and developing
factual evidence and that sort of thing
so I've always understood uh briefing to
be an opportunity for me as an attorney
to raise arguments I've never understood
it to be a requirement obviously if I'm
given a briefing opportunity and I
failed to use it or I failed to use it
adequately that's on me but I've never
seen a tribunal before reserve the
authority to require me to submit a
brief particularly at any time in the
process that's that is something that
you should think about the idea that the
Pu can just at any point when it occurs
to it it can tell parties to submit
briefs now I I'm I'm less concerned
about that than the department is
because I I really think that for the
finish the Pu can't really require a
party to submit a brief I mean we'll
have to test that we'll see the first
time I lose a case because I didn't
submit a brief when the Pu told me to
then I'll go before chief justice
McDonald and his colleagues and we'll
see uh how they think about that but I I
I I I I hear the concern of the
department about that less worried about
it than they are my concern has to do
with the settlement provision in the
proposed rules and now I will let Miss
kavara talk to you on behalf of the
utilities thank
you thank you attorney cre uh my
comments will be relatively brief um
attorney Cree covered a lot of of the uh
points that I was going to make I I
wanted to say that there is a lot of
what attorney Fuller said that I I do
agree with including the efforts that
went into these roles and the
collaboration that that was extended uh
to the utilities to resolve issues right
up into the last minute um and and
that's very much appreciated um I I I do
want to make some points uh I think
something was referenced about uh
parties seeking a rubber stamp of
settlements that that is not what we're
seeking um when parties enter into
settlement agreements they are doing so
knowing that the standard is that it
should be just and reasonable in the
public interest but it should also be
evaluated such that it is the overall
result of the settlement that would be
just and reasonable and in the public
interest by changing the standard to the
provisions of the settlement needing to
be just and reasonable and in the public
interest I understand that the Pu said
today it's not their intention for take
cases to be litigated but if the
practical fact is as attorney C just
said that he's not going to take the
risk of entering into settlement
negotiations if the doe decides they're
not going to engage in the risk of
entering into settlement negotiations
because they will just end up having to
incur the cost of litigation anyways the
utilities won't have anyone to bargain
with and there there may be also
interveners to the case but without the
de without the doe and the OCA there
those are two very important voices and
so even if it's not their intent the
practical effect will be an extreme
chilling effect on the ability of
parties to negotiate settlement and it's
that practical effect that we're
concerned with but when we do put when
parties come together often very diverse
parties with very diverse interests if
we can come together on all the issues
in a docket and put forward a cohesive
hole that says this resolves every issue
in this docket and the result of it is
just and
reasonable I I I don't think it's
necessarily appropriate to subject that
line by line and look at every element
in isolation because that it's it's an
anema to to Settlements a the concept of
settlements as a whole uh because it it
it does it fails to look at that hole
and so that that's really all I have to
say and I'm I'm happy to take
questions question representative Le I
have question really for the consumer
Advocate if if I'm understanding
correctly you're saying
that even under the existing
rule you're troubled by the way the Pu
is now acting in sort of uh really fly
specking or really nitpicking settlement
agreements and not approving them so I
guess my question is really if they're
doing it now under the existing rule um
if we I mean what's the you know why
don't we just leave the existing rule
the way it is and they'll and if you
have a problem you'll I guess you'll
litigate it at some point but I I don't
I guess I don't quite understand what
you're worried about if they're already
doing under the existing rule what you
don't
like that's an excellent question so
thank you for asking that
and so here here's the reality the the
Pu has always engaged in some degree of
cherry picking settlements and and
usually or historically the cherry
picking has involved deciding that oops
the consumer Advocate and the Pu staff
now the department of energy they didn't
even go far enough so we're going to
impose some additional conditions on
whatever utility is before the
commission and then given the way the
rules and given the way uh settlements
are always structured it really became
the job of the utility to decide am I
going to just swallow this
or am I going to litigate this and the
utility every time I had ever seen that
happen decided all right we'll go along
with it we'll we'll take the additional
haircut imposed by the regulator and
everybody lives happily ever after uh I
if you change the rule to make it even
more consistent with the rule uh that
the Pu can cherry pick settlements then
this process gets even more difficult in
the way that I've articulated I if I'm
understanding what you're saying is this
will just sort of En changing the
language will encourage them to do it
even more yes that that is what I'm
saying and and what I would also ask you
to think about is in a scenario where
you have the consumer Advocate
representing residential rate payers the
department of energy representing the
executive branch and its plenary
authority over the you know the the the
general good of the state whatever
utility or utilities are involved and
whatever other parties have chosen to
intervene when you have all of those
parties coming before the Pu and saying
here's the answer here is a reasonable
compromise of all these issues I mean
yes the Pu has some independent
authority to uh assess whether that all
is in the public interest but what does
the Pu add to that consensus when it
includes all of the parties whose
interests the Pu could conceivably be
expected to resolve now remember
attorney Fuller told you the pu's
statutory job is to serve as the Arbiter
between the interests of utility
shareholders and the interests of
utility customers it is a big deal when
the Pu tells us and you that it knows
better than what the shareholders and
the customers have agreed
to questions from the committee would
you like your options uh yeah actually
just want to ask I have a question I do
want my options but um I have a question
so uh Mr gree if a provision if a
settlement was put forward that had one
of the things I'm reading is that the
agreement that the provisions of the
settlement are consistent with the
applicable law right so let's just use
that one
criteria if all those parties got
together and put together a proposal for
a settlement that wasn't appropriate to
the application of law that was in
violation of the application of law
wouldn't it be appropriate for the Pu to
reject that provision just on that
reason alone
yes I wonder if I could just ask a
question to the staff am am I
understanding that the the the change in
the language on the settlement aspect is
from reviewing the results of the
settlement to reviewing the provisions
of the settlement or is it more
complicated so it's slightly more
complicated so the original rule is was
uh
20320 B and it reads the commission
shall approve a disposition of any
contested Case by stipulation settlement
consent or order or default it if it
determines that the result is just and
reasonable and serves the public
interest the proposed rule reads it's
20410 B it's on page 43 of the
conditional approval packet and it reads
the commission shall approve a
disposition of any cont contested Case
by settlement agreement if it is
determined that provisions of the
settlement agreement are consistent with
the applic law are just and reasonable
and serve the public interest so they've
changed the the language from the result
to
Provisions my analysis is that it
doesn't change that much but it clearly
people are are disagreeing with that
so thank thank you that's that's very
helpful so want you give us our options
here so uh jel car at this point can
either approve the rule you can object
to the rule on the basis of pu 20410 B
which is the one I just read um or you
could postpone um the tenative January
meeting is the 17th and your deadline is
not till the
21st uh
s uh object to
2041b okay
question on
procedure is represent is Senator avar
was he seated yes oh I I apologize I
apologize so soar you're you're so to do
a preliminary objection which is what
you're asking to do we we have to give a
reason so what's the reason for the
preliminary objection so they can
respond I think it just complicates
things and I'm going to narrow it down
to just more bureaucracy sorry so my
understanding is that the objection is
to 20410 B um because the language is uh
unclear and unable to be enforced
uniformally thank you okay you're very
good at this all right so Senator avars
made a motion to a preliminary objection
based on uh
ambiguity and has been seconded by
Senator Andis which I think was also
seated so all five Senators here there
any further discussion yeah I guess I
would say I'm I'm going to vote to you
know consistent with with the with the
preliminary objection but I have to say
particularly in light of of the language
that's been read but I really agree with
the staff that I don't really see much
if any substantive difference here
between the language and
um so for that I mean for that reason
you know maybe it doesn't it we should
just leave the language the way it is it
sounds like though from what the
consumer Advocate has said I I think his
testimony was very helpful that maybe
there is a problem with the
Pu uh sort of nitpicking uh settlements
that that and that may or I'm not I
don't know whether that's true or not
but if it but if it is I'm not sure that
anything that we would do here would
make much of a difference but I so for
that reason I'm gonna I'm going to
support U Senator aar's motion to
clarify also the preliminary objection
does give the agency the chance to go
back and talk to stakeholders and make
and they can make no change and keep it
the way it is or they can make a change
and maybe they can come up with better
language it just gives them more time to
do that so we will see the
result so again the motion is a you have
a comment yes thank you Mr chair I'm uh
I agree with representative L that it's
distressing that we've got three
agencies here fighting it out this is
not the proper venue for such a uh for
such an action and I hope that by
objecting you'll be able to clarify the
language so that you all understand what
it means thank
you further
discussion all those in favor of the
preliminary objection say I I all those
oppos nay the eyes have
it next up is higher
education uh scholarships for Orphans
and Veterans uh 24
-19 okay there are no substantive
comments on this proposal we wanted it
on the regular agenda to bring up the
FIS the fiscal impact statement issue so
um it appears to be inadequate because
it didn't State all of the cost and
benefits to Citizens or independently
owned businesses so the Department's
request for FAL impact statement did
bring up these these benefits and costs
but the the LBA did not follow that
through and put that in the fiscal
impact statement which is a concern for
us we've seen some inconsistencies with
the lb's F's but we just wanted to point
out that there are benefits to Citizens
and independently own businesses as the
scholarship funds amounts are changing
and so that would cause a benefit which
again the the agency pointed out the LBA
did not so great go ahead guys good
morning Steve division director
Department of Education um this
scholarship fund has existed for many
years the legislature appropriates
$10,000 a year um to uh potential
individuals with a maximum of $2,500 per
award um this rule update the rule was
expiring we proceeded to uh work with
legal counsel at the department to
update the rule which is the proposal
you have before you um probably the
biggest change would be we brought the
rule back in compliance with the
statutory language uh the previous rule
that was expiring limited this statute
to students attending our public
colleges and the statute doesn't say
that it just says colleges so we've um
moved back to that language so that uh
potentially a student attending one of
our private colleges or universities
could uh apply for this which is uh you
know affects the fiscal impact uh to
Citizens and private businesses uh being
the colleges questions from the
committee seeing a motion for
conditional approval don't move been
moved by sen in is seconded by
representative ly any further discussion
on this rule seeing onone all those in
favor say I I all oppos n the eyes have
it thank you
guys next up is uh the board of dental
examiners we're going to take up uh take
up well we're going to postpone uh
actually I'll make a motion to postpone
185 do I have a second second it's been
seconded by second we are going to
postpone rule 24 that's 185 till a
January
meeting I moved it representative
Maguire second all those favor a
postpone of 248 185 say i i poose n
thank that's postponed to next month we
take up uh
24226 uh use of general anesthetic uh
sedation by dentists and AG
first
okay okay so um there is a conditional
approval on this text and I have no
further substantive comments um there
has been a lot of public
testimony I can say that the rule itself
as it's written um does comply with the
statute 317
a12 um some of the testimony raised an
issue of essentially there's a section
they or There are rules that they feel
are left out in terms of an emergency
situation um but the text of the rule
does comply with the statute and that is
all the comments I have great
a good morning my name is Elizabeth
Eaton I'm Council to the board of dental
examiners uh this is Tina Kelly she's
one of our rules coordinators at oplc uh
I have with me two board members because
I can't speak to anything uh related to
the actual practice of Dentistry um or
anesthesia but if you would indulge me
briefly I'd like to take you through the
Journey these rules have um taken to
arrive here today to understand the
context uh in which these public
comments come in uh the New Hampshire
Board of dental examiners was tasked
with promulgating new rules for general
anesthesia deep sedation moderate
sedation following statut changes
several years ago the rules before you
today have been a work in progress for a
long time with the most concentrated
productive work taking place over the
last two years the board followed every
relevant law and Rule throughout the
entire process and I would like to outl
outline that timeline briefly the
initial proposal was published in the
rul making register on July 3rd 2024 on
July 4th 2024 the initial proposal was
published on the board's website
an email to all lenses uh under the
board of dental examiners was sent
providing notice of these rules as well
as the date of the rules hearing for
public comment that was sent on July 16
2024 the same information contained in
that email was published on the board's
web web page on July 17th 2024 and that
email was sent to
3530 people and of that number
278 people opened that email the board
heard testimony at the public hearing on
August 5th 2024 and took written
testimony until August 15 2024 before
compiling the comments discussing them
adjusting the draft accordingly and
responding to each comment as required
by law comments continued to come to the
board after the deadline of August 15th
and the board continued to consider each
one you can see in the summary of public
comment the board accepted written
comments until mid
October at the November meeting the
board accepted public comment during the
public session of their meeting and
heard more from lenses about these rules
they made last minute adjustments to the
final proposal after considering the
comments made um and then voted to file
the final proposal I'm trying to
emphasize the board's efforts to comply
with all relevant law while also
considering the expertise of New
Hampshire oral health professionals as
well as nationally Rec recognized
standards no set of rules is perfect but
at some point they need to move forward
here the board voted to move these rules
forward for your consideration knowing
there is a substantial there is
substantial protest from some New
Hampshire oral health professionals
knowing this the board voted at their
December meeting to request rulemaking
support from the office so when these
rules are adopted the board can
immediately initiate rulemaking to make
potential amendments to den
304 the respected oral health
professionals in New Hampshire will have
another bite at the anesthesia apple as
soon as bureaucracy
allows thank
you questions I think we're have two
board members come up to speak to the
application of the rule versus just the
rule
itself represent LE thank you Mr
chairman um I do have a question about
where the authority for separating out
Children eight and under from 13 and
under comes from because in my reading
of the statute there's no separate
differentiation between those age
groups I would um prefer to defer to the
uh experts here but my understanding is
it is a it is
a guideline um under the national
standards or nationally accepted
standards uh to separate out
um I I think I'll have a Dr AEL or Dr I
can respond to that in just a
moment so the stature is um so let me
introduce myself I'm Dr lington and this
is Dr Abel one second doc me uh attorney
respond the statute is uh
317a 12 and it is Roman numeral uh 12- a
and I think
it's G or H H um so the patients under
age 13 shall be subject to additional
rules including and then there's there's
more criteria and so our interpretation
was that they set the line at 13 but
allowed them to write rules regarding
the different sections 0 through 8 to 9
through 13 does that make
sense um it does you're you're allowing
them to give more granularity um than
what is specifically laid out and I
understand I understand that choice I
think that's what the statute
says Dr lton go introduce your we are
can you introduce both of you yes I'm Dr
Lon I'm Dr AEL I'm an oral surgeon I
practice in
Manchester I'm an endid and I practice
in Portsmouth
um both Dr Abel and I are here for the
um betterment of the p people of New
Hampshire and the children of New
Hampshire that's who we're really
representing uh we went through a lot of
literature and realized that we wanted
to find an age that had the least amount
of impact on access to care but was the
safest approach to
Children uh we came up with nine after
doing that and um it seemed as though
physiologically um it's a lot easier to
treat someone over nine in that setting
than it is under nine so that was how
the age was pecked so that we compromis
the uh access to care as well as the
safety of the
children on
seconde go ahead
sir I mean I I agree with everything Dr
lington just
said okay
great uh represent sen
there thank you Mr chairman
um my question is on the specificity
between ages 8 and ages
13 uh Pals covers eight and under
generally many of the treatments are
weight weight dosed or weight
dependent versus age dependent but
generally Pal's guidelines are applied
eight and under so in these rules 30
30407 a8a removes the ACLS requirement
under the age of 13 so what do you do
between ages 8 and 13 if we pass these
rules maybe that's a question for for
somebody else but in your in your view I
think I I heard you mention age nine
actually you're specifically referring
to a requirement for ACLS yeah correct
what's your opinion on that okay well um
there's three types of permits that are
permitted for providers and the permit
for general anesthesia deep sedation
would require ACLS and Pals because they
can give it to any age from zero up to
know 100 um the the moderate sedation
permits um if it's 13 and above they
have to have ACLS if it's nine and above
because there's a pediatric moderate
permit they'd have to have Pals and ACLS
so the proposed rules remove the ACLS
requirement for under the age of 13 and
require Pals only
but Pal's guidelines generally apply up
to the age of
eight and you treat patients over the
age of eight under emergency Cardiac
Care guidelines taught through
ACLS right so there's a gap so the rules
as proposed are potentially flawed I
mean there are times where your clinical
assessment has you
treat patients under the age of eight
because of their weight or size or your
clinical judgment judement you'll treat
them under ACLS guidelines even if
they're under eight or under Pal's
guidelines if they're over eight weight
do I mean you understand the clinical
judgment involved yes and you're from
Manchester so you certainly remember the
tragic case that occurred at an oral
surgeon's office in Manchester where
there was a lack of ACLS and that
patient
died yes I I apologize Senator I think
there may be a misunderstanding of the
rules do you mind if I go through them
with you
um so U there is a requirement for Pals
and ACLS if you look at uh section Den
30404 which is qualifications for
permitting no I'm I'm familiar but in
these proposed rules that ACLS
requirement is
removed where where do you see that
Senator um it's page I think
13 13 of
132 uh it it removes it for Pediatric
patients under
13 do do you have the specific rule
number I apologize Ru number uh
304 304
what
30407 a8a
8 okay so it it just creates a bit of a
gap okay okay between eight and 13 and
and potentially elsewhere if there's a
certain clinical case so that was a
response to feedback we got from um
various uh providers the qualified
provider is going to be your anesthesia
provider so if you look at the
definitions in the beginning the
qualified provider could be a dentist
who has a general anesthesia deep
sedation permit it could be a medical
anesthesiologist or it could be a nurse
um anesthetist this uh eight that you're
referring to is saying the second person
so you already have that
anesthesiologist the second person is
going to be your dentist who's doing the
filling or extraction or whatever the
procedure is that's the person who is
okay to have BLS because they're like
the backup person if you
will okay I follow you but you you
really can't care
for in an emergency Cardiac Care
situation uh ACLS and Pals teaches you
fundamentally a team approach right the
whole course is based on a team approach
and and the very
first part of either of those curricula
is you can't do this alone it's the
first and last thing you
teach is you can't do it alone in fact
they teach it takes a minimum of three
and preferably six
for American Heart Association
guidelines for either ACLS or Pals and I
know you know that because I'm sure
you're ACLS or Pal certified yes yes uh
Senator I so so the decision is just um
you know with access to care if you will
so we're if we do that you know if we do
what you're what you're proposing then
every dentist who wants to bring in an
anesthesiologist whether they're doing a
filling or whatever procedure would have
to have a ACS and that is the vast
majority of dentists in New Hampshire do
not have ACLS unless they're anesthesia
training that's for oral Conscious
Sedation you're talking about right in
in the dental
ACLS Dental ALS course that's oral
Conscious Sedation that's take take
to triazolam in the waiting room right
we're talking about general anesthesia
here that oral Maxwell facial surgeons
are trained in you know 32e residency I
read your papers and um I mean that's
that's a different that's a that's a
different type of sedation oral
Conscious Sedation take two pills in the
waiting room different story general
anesthesia malenotti grade four
Airway dies fentel adverse event
different situation right we're talking
about two different animals here all
right I I don't I don't think I am
talking about deep sedation general
anesthesia because in the den 3044 it's
it's requiring that the dentist who's
going to have that deep sedation general
anesthesia permit has to have ACLS imp
Pals and then in Den 3047 that you're
referring to it's talking about the
dentist the the operator the the surgeon
if you will having to also you're you're
saying they should also have ACLS and
Pals which we could certainly do if
that's what the consensus on the
committee is but that's going to be even
more of access to care issue because now
every dentist in the state's going to
have to have ACLS to bring in an
anesthesiologist no I'm asking you about
removing the requirement
for
ACLS to treat to treat any patient under
general anesthesia in a dental office I
don't think we did that because as I was
saying in Den 3044 qualifications for
permitting I read it it's still says
that they have to have ACLS and Pals um
but for for these in the Pediatric
setting where I think it's actually even
more dangerous U that's that's my
opinion I guess
um
3047 30407 this is Page uh I'm on page
12 I guess
actually response this is from Matt
Smith
30407 a8a has been rewarded to remove
the requirement for ACLS certification
this is under facility and facility
hosting requirements and it's specific
to the
um the Pediatric patient I believe
right so so that feedback that was
feedback we took into consideration from
the Pediatric Dental Community
specifically because they predominantly
treat young children so they were
concerned that if we required all of the
pediatric dentists to get both ACLS and
Pals it was kind of like an unnecessary
hurdle because they're not treating
adults they're treating children no I
know I understand I
agree but I maybe it's the age cut off
that we need to talk about then it's 13
eight it's the 8 to 13 Gap I guess so
what do you what do you do right if if
you don't have ACLS and you only have
Pals and you're treating under 13 so
maybe it's the age Gap that we need to
talk about okay my point is rules are
flawed as they're submitted I guess I
guess that's that's rather than taking
up any more time of the committee thank
you Mr
chairman thank you all right further
questions from the committee for the
doctors and board
members so we heard from um in the rules
my concern again around the Pediatric
Dentistry there's a question of whether
you need two providers or only a single
provider for for children and as I did
my research and trying to understand the
the law that was passed and the law that
was passed that for patients under 13
two providers were required is that
correct correct that was in 2018 HB
1577 and so these rules are looking to
reflect that and my as a followup to
that
um the argument was that in that same
law they gave the board authority to
create exemptions for surgeons correct
correct and what the board did was it it
created those exemptions for the
children under from 9 to 13 and said
that you have one set of criteria um
which is um you can only have you could
have one person who is certified in all
the appropriate Provisions but if you
were under the age of eight you had to
have two provider or eight and under you
had to have two providers an
anesthesiologist whose only job is to
monitor the child and then the surgeon
whose job is to do the actual work is
that my understanding what these rules
are looking to ad do and adopt yes
that's correct so the question came up
about emergencies and I had this
question too kid goes to the emergency
room with a baseball bat to the face
they call a surgeon the uh and the kid
is transported to the doctor's office
for for whatever necessary work is
needed to done due to this baseball bat
to the face
and they don't have an anesthesiologist
and a kid's eight years
old what happens okay so we have three
Provisions in that situation which we
responded to in the feedback um that was
provided to the committee um so one
option would be to give the child
moderate sedation if you felt they
needed sedation don't give them the full
deep where they're unconscious give them
a conscious moderate sedation instead um
another option would be to bring in a
separate anesthesia providers so that
could be again um certified registered
nurse anesthetist it could be a dentist
anesthesiologist could be a physician um
and then your third option would be to
take them to the hospital or surgery
center and actually when hb1 1577 was
passed by the legislature in 2018
something that I thought was uh very
shrewd on behalf of the legislature is
they actually looked at the statutes
that involved insurance
reimbursement and they they raised the
age for the requirement for anesthesia
facility reimbursement for dental
procedures to 13 whereas it was
six so I I feel like the legislature has
done everything it can to provide
alternatives to the public beyond having
a dentist give general anesthesia to the
child with just the staff and no
anesthesiologist
there
okay so one more fell so again trying to
understand this and the concerns of
access of care which I think is like one
of the big concerns that was discussed
by providing having required two
providers that surgeons would have a
trouble providing care for students for
patients or delay care patients but when
I read the 2019 there was a guideline
put out by both the uh um AAP uh the
association of pediatric um providers as
well as the associate Association for um
dental pediatric dental providers it
specifically requires for kids under uh
it says that two children two should be
required for under age8 in their own
guidelines for pediatric dentists so is
that again did you take these kind of
rules at looking at the AP and the
whatever the one is for the pediatric
dentists um those model guidelines and
use that to develop the uh Provisions
that were put forth go yes so um the
scientific bodies in dentistry which
would include the American Association
of Orland Max loation surgeons the
American Society of dentists the
anesthesiologists the American Academy
of pediatric dentistry they have done a
number of excellent Publications and
research on their own part about making
in office anesthesia for dentists as
safe as possible so we looked at theirs
and then we also looked at Medical
Publications so what you're referring to
is a publication that was a joint
publication between the American Academy
of Pediatrics which is a physic
organization and the American Academy of
pediatric dentistry and where the two
collaborated and published that document
they were saying there should be a
separate provider for deep sedation
general anesthesia for young children
right specifically say however we're
aware of adverse outcomes when single
dental provider simultaneously performs
the procedure and administers deep set
sedation or general anesthesia for
dental procedures and then these
guidelines assure the safety of patients
to undergo the procedure so your goal
was to deal with those adverse effects
for younger patients and yet still give
the the surgeons some wiggle room and
the older kids for lack of Ben phrase
Senator Lang one of the things that we
took into account is there's a balance
between safety and access to care and we
tried to come up with a compromise that
would work the best for everyone and it
is difficult at times my I'm an
endodontist I deal with emergencies
there are people this afternoon that
don't know my name that I'll be seeing
and there's a certain segment of
emergencies that have to go to the
hospital and there're certain that you
can deal with but in our community
um I have yet to see and I deal with
trauma to the face all the time uh a
collaboration of of providers that can't
give that patient access to
care further questions about the Comm
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um and thank thank you
gentleman for coming and bringing this
expertise um I'm sure you're thankful
that you practice in Manchester where
there are a lot of other providers
around you um and I think that one of
the things to look at is the um the
guidelines such as from the association
of oral maxf facial surgeons who were
able to balance the needs both in highly
populated areas and those more rural
areas with less access to care um and
I'm curious how you weighted the safety
of children up in the north country with
their access to care should they not be
able to make it down to an area like
Manchester in order to get these
procedures
done um there's a few comments I can
make about that I guess the first is um
the legislature seemed to make it quite
clear in 2018 when they passed House
Bill 1577 that there should be a
separate anesthesia provider uh for ages
12 and under now they did Grant the
Dental Board the authority to determine
a s a policy for exemptions to oral
surgeons however the legislature could
have said we exempt all oral surgeons
but they didn't um the next move of the
D board was one year later the Dental
Board said well we'll just exempt all
oral surgeons and then the Dental Board
was audited a couple of years later by
the Legislative budget assistant and it
was determined that no you you can't
just you can't just exempt all oral Surs
you have to have a a protocol for
determining how this can be done safely
um and balancing what Dr lington was
saying access to care with patient
safety uh the board provided a number of
documents to the committee um that
highlight how
specifically the age under six age group
is very at risk of um life-threatening
complications from anesthesia that could
be um progressing to a deeper level of
sedation than was intended uh it could
be some sort of an airway uh compromise
situation um and in those situations
it's much more challenging to rescue the
young child versus an older patient so
when you refer to more rural parts of
the state um I guess I guess the
decision for the committee is and for
the legislature in general is um do we
feel that the risk you know the risk
versus um access to care um you know uh
scale is it is it tilted more towards
risk when you get to a very young
patient population um and the um the
Dental Board felt that yes for the under
for the eight and underage group The
requirement for a separate provider for
deep sedation general anesthesia the
risk outweighed the benefit now like I
said they could still do moderate
sedation in the rural area they could
still bring in a separate provider or
they could still take them to a hospital
setting if they need deep sedation but
their other option would be
moderate can I can I speak for one
minute um in the health care professions
this is the only segment that allows for
one provider to be present for a child
doing the procedure and doing the
anesthesia only place in healthc care
profession if you go for colonoscopy and
you're 50 years old there's going to be
an anesthesiologist there there's going
to be a doctor there so I really think
that um we need to become in line with
the general population of medical
providers follow sorry yes as a followup
um I I guess I wasn't quite sure how not
how doing a 32- we rotation in
anesthesiology wasn't considered an
adequate quit qualification for the oral
maxi facial surgeons since that's
required for board lure that wouldn't
feel like a blanket statement but now
I'm trying to understand how you can
look at data for Pediatric patients six
and under and then apply those rules to
patients eight and under I appreciate
how you're trying to balance patient
safety but um to me looking at it
looking at how the rules have been
implemented um to me it just seems too
far from where the legislative intent is
with how the rules are being implemented
um so I I still continue to have a a
significant problem with how they're
implemented although I appreciate how
you're trying to balance safety first so
I appreciate that effort I just disagree
on how it's being done representative
Lynn thank thank you Mr chair I wonder
if I could ask uh just could you tell us
um generally around the country um other
states you know what is their rule with
regard if if we were to adopt this
proposal would we be
consistent with what the majority of
other states do or would we have more
restrictions than most States my
understanding is um New Hampshire would
be the first state to actually require
the second provider under a certain age
group now there are other states that
have a more restrictive policy for which
oral surgeons would qualify to get a
permit um for instance um I we provided
to the committee um the model um oral
American Academy of pediat or I'm sorry
the American Academy of periodontics
American Association of oral surgeons
and American Society of dentist
anesthesiologist proposed rules which
some states have adopted and that
requires for ages eight and under these
are their official national guidelines
ages eight and under you can get a
permit to provide deep sedation general
anesthesia however you have to do at
least 50 cases every two years to
qualify for the permit so that would be
a small number of oral surgeons that
would qualify but they could still get
the permit if they do that volume of
patients and can I ask a followup one
follow can you tell us uh I i' I've
heard that and I don't and this is what
I'm really asking about that that the
the concern for children under eight
stems from a particularly unfortunate
incident that happened in California
which um apparently you know adopted
National notoriety but I I'm wondering
if you could tell us in the state that
have a looser requirement than this rule
would propose have there you know can
you tell us anything about have there
been a a a consistent history of
problems of you know of unfortunate
outcomes with with young children uh
yeah I would like to first of all um the
board and I was one that in initiated
this there was no reporting of any
adverse effect in the dental office
unless it was voluntary and now we are
requiring you to report if a patient is
admitted to the hospital within 48 Hours
even if it's not Dental related if if it
they were in your office they have to
report it to the Dental Board so they
can investigate unfortunately the only
time you hear about this is when there's
litigation last week there was an
article about a a mother whose son died
in an oral surgeon's office and was very
upset because she was a nurse and if
she'd have known there was only one
provider she wouldn't have allowed it to
happen because in the hospital they
don't allow it to happen so that data is
very hard to find and it only surfaces
when there's a a major lawsuit and it
gets in the papers so the reality of it
is we're not really sure other than the
fact that the medical model
of Physicians doesn't allow it to me
that's that says enough as far as the
standard of care and and the oral
surgeons are very well trained there's
no question about it most of them have
MDS that's not the issue the issue is
there's an
emergency you know use the example of uh
Miracle on the Hudson Sy had 20,000
hours 20 years of flying experience he
needed his co-pilot to help him land
that airplane this is what we're talking
about it's not the everyday thing it's
when there's an emergency having only
one person monitoring that patient
dealing with the emergency is not
acceptable if you can talk to Dr Abel
about the the the difficulty in starting
an IV of of of dealing with uh the
airway and all those things so that's
really the issue the issue is the
emergency not the
training further question further
questions from the
committee we have a couple more people
that want to
speak ask
question so I've had uh several oral
surgeons situations uh but I'm also uh a
fully grown human being uh of
considerable age uh and I know that it's
uh I've I've been operated on by very
competent individuals and it was not a
pleasant experience nobody would say
they the kind of thing we want to do on
your vacation um but the thing is that
we're not going to be able to provide
for
absolutely every situation when there's
an emergency uh one of the my colleagues
talked about a baseball bat to the face
of a child wouldn't be good with an
adult either so uh what is the Practical
result I I I'm listening I I have some
experience with this as I said I'm
listening and I'm wondering how many and
and representative Lan talked about
somebody up in the North Country they
they got to be helicoptered in to get
there within any kind of a reasonable
time frame and so forth we're not going
to be able to save EV absolutely
everybody under every circumstance
that's not that's not feasible so we
have to consider practicability and I
think Dr lington if I got your name
correct sir uh where you want to have
that second person and there I get that
but if you if you if you basically can't
have that then what are the Alternatives
so so representative if you're in the
North country and you have a heart
attack you go to the hospital and you
need bypass surgery they'll make it
happen we need to maybe adjust our our
delivery system but the bottom line is I
don't I don't I I won't know the
six-year-old that I saved his life but
access to care I think is really an
issue in this state the North Country
I'm fine I I literally have people drive
down to see me not because of my you
know office uh Decor or my personality
but they just like to come see me but
they can they go past probably five or
six idon on the way down here so the
reality of it is I don't I can't see in
this state the access to care in the
North Country being an issue when we're
looking at the safety of
children representative Lynn so I wonder
if I could just follow if I'm
understanding correctly and I think this
this this was something that I I didn't
understand and it's very helpful to know
this but if I understand correctly what
you're saying is that take it outside of
the dental context for a moment what
you're saying is in any other context
but Dentistry if somebody is going to be
put under uh under general anesthesia
there needs to be two people present is
that right so if that's
true if I'm understanding correctly then
the the dental these Dental regulations
would already make a an exception to
that for children that are over the age
of 13 or I'm sorry I'm sorry from 9 to
13 and over so so there's
already a difference which apparently
the dental Society thinks is okay to say
you don't need to have two people
present if if you're doing dental
surgery of some kind and the person is 9
years or older and so I I guess I mean
that really that significantly it seems
to me
undermines the idea that you know we're
making a big exception here because you
already you already are making a big
exception in that in that apparently
dental procedures are the only ones for
at least most people from nine up where
you don't have to have a second person
present and if you know if we're willing
to if we think or you think as experts
that that it's appropriate to take that
risk I guess I wonder why it's not
appropriate to take the risk for people
under age nine where
apparently many other states do
that so A few things about that
so um the American Association of or Max
facial surgeons has uh comprehensive
training requirements membership
requirements for oral surgeons in the
United States uh requiring that oral
surgeons uh have an office anesthesia
evaluation where their office is
inspected for handling medical
emergencies um as well as do quarterly
emergency training drills with their
office staff um uh attend an airway
emergency course every so often um so
there's a number of continuing education
requirements for oral surgeons to make
the office administration of dental
anesthesia as safe as possible um in
Additionally the oral surgeon is working
in the mouth which is the patients
Airway where they're breathing which is
the most common area of concern uh under
sedation that there would be a
respiratory emergency the oral surgeon
is right there to manage it now when we
get to a younger age group we provided
uh Publications to the committee that
shows how the risk versus um you you
know ease of of of Emergency Management
changes as the child gets younger once
they get in that specifically the six
and underage group although um you know
like I was saying the American
Association of oral Max facial surgeons
American Society of dentist
anesthesiologists and American Academy
of periodontology pick the age of eight
and under is a more risk age group um
the children are more susceptible to the
anesthesia they're more likely to have a
life-threatening Airway event and if you
have to rest resue them they'll be
harder to put in a breathing Tu they'll
be harder to do an emergency cryo
thyroidotomy mind of vain mind of veined
for all of that so that that was the
reason for picking specifically the
younger age group to require the second
provider thank
you thank you thank you gentlemen for
being here just on the reporting thing
with the you know if if if a child goes
to the hospital and reporting to the um
Dental Association or whatever
uh does any other state do that I'm
sorry does any other state do that as
far as the reporting when a child goes
under sedation I I can't really uh
answer that but the the uh incident that
that this gentleman was talking with the
Senate over here um that made the papers
and everything else but that that was
one of the things that brought light to
the Dental Board that we weren't
informed there's been a lot
of anesthesia emergencies that don't
resolve in a death but resolve in other
things and now they'll have to report
all of that so all of the stuff uh
having a linges b all these different
things that could happen that don't
result in a death um we're not just
talking about a patient dying we're
talking about you know what happens when
this you know child goes into this this
problem and uh so making it uh death
being the the final outcome that you
have to report no it's any adverse
effect so I can't answer that question
thank you can I
clarify um So based on the documents
that were submitted by the dental board
with the rule um my understanding is
that there's a problem across the
country without with not reporting these
types of things so it was it's difficult
for them to do some of the studies and
if I'm not mistaken the model rules for
the national
standards were wanting people to add
that portion in about the reporting back
to the Dental Board of the state
so it's not something that's done like
across the country but they're saying
like it needs to be done and we were the
one of the first boards to implement
that so sen I will tell you I researched
last night about this California has
already implemented a reporting Rule and
so is Arizona boast both due to adverse
incidents that occurred and legislation
that got brought forward that ended up
requiring uh this kind of reporting and
I I'm I'm agreeing with it 100% you know
as far as the reporting is there going
to be a fiscal impact for the other
medical agency at all that that we
should be aware of uh to report to you
to the board I'm having a hard time
hearing you I'm I'm sorry I've got a
loud voice well I yeah uh D drills will
there be
a b
banned uh is there a will there be a
fiscal impact for the other uh medical
uh facilities to report that's all
it's well I the only time you have to
report is when you have a we're hoping
that there's not a lot of
reports but that aners your question
good
answer so again I'm going to kind of
bring the committee back together so the
issue is that we could either object or
do anything on is around the access of
care issue and public good issue of the
rule and the new requirement um if I'm
not mistaken attorney will correct me I
think they're within the law um that
they that the rules they propose are
within the changes of the law and are
allowed by law is that correct yes my
allow analysis is that the rules are
compliant with the law thank you so it
becomes a question on ja car rules
whether or not the access of care is a
big enough issue as when compared to
patient safety uh for the rules they've
decided I think representative Lynn
earmarked it out very cleanly nine and
above you can have a single provider in
the room providing both the uh surgical
event as well as providing anesthesia
but at 8 and under um the new rule now
requires that there be two anesthesi
there be an anesthesiologist as well as
the doctor who's going to provide the
care in the room for children8 and under
due to the heightened risk of children
at8 and under and then the last
component which I was concerned about
was emergencies and the answer to that
seemed to be that if there was an
emergency and you didn't have access to
anesthesiologist within your practice
you would take them to the local
hospital and use the onall
anesthesiology anesthesiologist at the
local hospital to be able to still
provide that care does that summarize it
accurately 100% thank you
motion do we have testimony on the other
side of the issue we do have four more
people to testify thank you all right I
think we're all Jackie I apologize but
um I just want to make sure that what
you're saying
is we want to Institute a rule and then
we're going to collect the data to make
sure that the rule is what we need is
that right I'm not exactly so in 2018
the legislature determined that there
should be a separate anesthesia provider
ages 12 and under in all dental offices
but they gave the agency the Dental
Board the power to determine if there
should be exemptions for oral surgeons
so we looked from a safety standpoint
and determined what age that there
should be the two and what age there
could be an
exemption fine thank
you thank you guys next up we'll have um
Jonathan Bean
M you just state your name and the
organization you're from yes
sir um my name's uh Dr johnan Bean I'm a
the microphone yes
sir
better uh I'm a board certified oral and
Max facial surgeon uh operating at a
Manchester
and
pimbrook however I have also worked in
other regions of the state including the
North country in North Conway
Salem uh and
nashwa uh just uh to address some of the
things that were just mentioned I would
uh completely argue that North Country
does have an access of care issue
already and it's a challenge to even
staff our offices up there
what's more is if you were to have a
heart attack in the North Country I
doubt that you want a cabbage performed
at the memorial hospital down the
street um but uh you know I I agree with
um Dr ael's assessment that the question
has to
become uh risk versus access to care uh
I I think that that is something we we
do have to consider when we consider
these things um but I share a number of
my Donal colleagues concerns with the
rules that have been set out in D 304 in
regards to access to care and the
financial burden that is placed on the
patient uh I currently hold privileges
at CMC and Elliot Hospital Systems I
previously held uh privileges at St
Joe's and Southern I will tell you that
as it stands currently
today uh there is little to no oral
surgery coverage at the hospital in this
state um Plymouth is at about 100% I
believe and then Dartmouth at 100%
Elliott has about 60% of oral surgery
coverage for 365 days out of the
year uh which means that if there is a
child that falls in this age range that
gets hit in the face with a bat I I
don't know that I would use that example
right off but uh if they have a dental
infection because they haven't been able
to get access to care because they
haven't been able to get into an office
that has an anesthesia provider and I
doubt that that anesthesia provider is
going to be ready to go on a moment's
notice for that emergency by the way
they're a month behind scheduling
out um then that person that kid has to
be transferred to a tertiary Center such
as Dartmouth or Boston Hospital assuming
that that hospital even has a bed
available for them otherwise that kid is
stuck with minimal Management in an ER
until adequate care can be
found um I recently was consulted on a
5-year-old kid uh little girl that had a
dental infection associated with a caras
or cavity um on her tooth uh and uh
infection had involved the left side of
her face um she was admitted to the
Elliott hospital system administered IV
antibiotics and I was consulted on the
case I eventually took that patient to
the operating room for removal of that
single tooth drainage of her facial
infection
and uh the infection did eventually
resolve however that 5-year-old had to
sit up in the hospital for 5 days being
treated with uh this condition face
swellen miserable with her parent in
attendance um offer a procedure that
could have been managed in outpatient
under
$1,000 uh and currently in insured an
uninsured patient that had that
experience is likely to be build
somewhere around 40 to
$50,000 so uh in addition to the
terrible experience that she had sitting
up there the financial burden that's
placed on that patient and her family is
very
significant this change these changes
that we are making with d
304 they are going to alter our access
to care we can debate all day on how
much but we are going to push a number
of these patients into the hospital
system to be treated
a hospital system that currently does
not have the means to manage it so my
concern is that if these rules go
through as they are written and I think
they're poorly written to say the least
uh not just on the basis of what they're
doing um if they go through then we're
going to create a significant burden on
our patients in all of these areas not
just the North Country on access to here
um I recommend that this committee um
move these rules back to the board for
further discussion and
revision thank
you questions for the
doctor seeing none thank you Doctor oh
I'm sorry uh representative Leon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
doctor for being here um my question is
about um the medical consequences the
mortality and morbidity of these
children that are going untreated
because of lack of access to care versus
the risk of adverse reaction to the
anesthesia right uh even in their own
data that they submitted to you was over
media references uh had a total I
believe of 44 deaths over the course of
about a 30-year period from 1980s to
like 2011 and yeah roughly deaths in New
Hampshire in in the United States sir
yeah in the United States uh in of those
deaths that are listed there in that
paperwork I believe um seven uh were
from anesthesiologist eight were from
oral surgeons the remainder were not
really classified very well between
Pediatric and general dentistry of which
their anesthesia training is very
unclear um so if you consider the number
of sedations that are done across the
country over that time by Oral Surgeons
who do in the dental office
approximately 80 to 85% roughly uh the
number of sedations in the
US uh in a 30-year period if they are
working working 200 days uh out of the
Year roughly um and they average three
three to four sedations a day um you're
going to be looking at uh you know
approximately a million sedations a year
roughly uh give or take um at 44 deaths
over 30 years you're now looking at a
mortality rate that's somewhere around 1
point two over a million cases um so uh
the rate that you would see for dental
abscess or infection and the potential
for it to progress to something that
involves the airway complicates the
airway for the anesthesia providers even
in the operating
room uh is probably similar you know or
higher now if you add into to the fact
that you're letting this kid just sit
there and progress into one of these
scenarios um you know understand the
definitive treatment there's some provid
that may try to say that you know
antibiotics would be you know well they
can get antibiotics they can get oral
antibiotics they can get IV antibiotics
that's true up to a point and there's a
certain percentage put on the scenario
that are not going to respond to that IB
antibotics those are the kids that see
me ultimately in the hospital right so
these are children that have already had
the opportunity to be treated as an
outpatient by their dentist by
specialist and they have not had
definitive care they don't have
something called Source control as a
surgeon uh any surgeon would tell you
general surgery uh trauma uh Orthopedics
that if you have any kind of
infection uh the The Source control is
the most important part so that you have
to be able to in our case take out a
tooth bad tooth on a kid in order to
have control over that infection if you
cannot do that you are not adequately
treating that infection always has a
chance to progress that bacteria has a
chance to become more virent um so yes
it it creates a bigger and bigger
problem the longer you wait and the
increase in access to cure so to answer
your question
[Music]
Senator thank you Mr chairman I've just
got a question for you about this this
44 number over 30 years and the data
reporting we we' had a little discussion
about sure whether we should report more
and and how whether that's even accurate
and and well and how well how good we
were generally across the country at
collecting data on adverse events and
and if there was an adverse event in a
dental office that was
subsequently transp recognized and
transported to the ER and then resulted
as a death would that be included in
that number especially 5 10 20 30 years
ago and then if you like you did
extrapolate 44 years or 44 deaths on an
ongoing basis to come up with some other
number right how valid is is that data
at all especially going back 25 30 years
yeah sorry yeah that's uh very uh fair
question that data is probably not
perfect uh no doubt um as far as it
being 44 deaths over that
time um which is part of the argument
they actually make in that article um
however uh what I would you know say and
uh against that is that if you look at
our state there's probably there's
approximately 50 of us that are
registered within um new New Hampshire
uh
Society of oral MX Facial Surgery uh 30
of us are probably full-time within the
state itself and don't go
outside uh that's about the size of a
small class or decent classroom in the
state of New Hampshire I can guarantee
you if one of us had a death in this
state every single one of us would at
least know about it um that being said
like how it's reported how you access
that from other states not perfect and I
actually agree with Dr lington that that
should be like the reporting is very
important and I think that that is
something that should be included
personally but uh I I don't disagree
with the reporting aspect of it that's
very
important uh Senator inis thank you
doctor for being here appreciate it um
just a couple quick questions you
administer anesthesia in your work is
that correct yes okay and you charge the
patients or the insurance companies for
that right uh not the same as an
anesthesia provider typically no okay in
what way is it different uh less time so
uh for example if you come in to my
office for
a
uh I ran ball poll when I was 12 so
let's say I show up I metal across the
if you have this is this may be a little
more personal preference on how I
practice but uh no generally as a whole
we tend to build less of our time uh
than the anesthesia providers within the
state
um you know if you come in and you have
a procedure that uh is you know 2 hours
long let's say it's extensive whatever
it is you're haven't done it was
uh so uh I'm not going to bill for that
whole time on anesthesia yeah I have a
cut off and that just has to do with the
total financial burden I'm putting on
somebody okay um that's a conscious
decision and uh most of my partners act
in that same way in other states I
practice in I've actually charged even
less uh so to think in a state that
you're already charging you're probably
one of the more you know New Hampshire
as a whole is one of the more expensive
States uh to get dental care as a whole
you're now going to increase that cost
significantly just as an outpatient not
to mention the inpatient risk and
increase you're going to see uh I I
think
that's it's tough because you're you're
looking at it you're trying to be safe
for these pediatric cases I understand
but you're going to incur an increased
cost uh what's more is as I as I
understand it these anesthesia providers
in the state that uh kind of uh provide
services in these offices most of them
have minimums on how much that they bill
for so if you are a six-year-old kid
coming to outside office and you have
one tooth that needs to come out and it
takes all of five minutes for me to do
that procedure that anesthesia provider
says no I'm going to build for the full
hour so it has to be that that that case
that that person can sit and monitor
that patient for at least an hour to
make it worth their while to show up in
your office that's how it is right now
so thank you um so you you mentioned you
would use general anesthesia for an
extraction is that yeah every day really
mhm okay yeah I'm not treating the
surgery I'm treating your
anxiety right that's what the anesthesia
is for but the surgery I can do I have
patients that do that a weake and I have
patients that are like don't touch me
you know well yeah all right thank
you so doc I just have two questions yes
sir so my two questions are
um do you think do you believe that the
A and the other one the
aapd um guideline that says that
children under eight are at more
susceptible risk for deepen for adverse
injury due to deep or general anesthetic
do you agree with that as you just said
statement yes I agree with that
statement I would say that there is this
underlying notion uh that by providing
the second provider even having an
anesthesiology uh dedicated provider
there that you're removing the
risk you're not removing the risk the
risk is never zero soon as you push that
first medication that risk is not zero
so what they're suggesting is hopefully
a means to reduce that risk but if
you'll note in every single one of those
guidelines that were submitted that I I
mean I kind of glanced at I couldn't
find any data that they're referencing
to make those guidelines and I'm not
aware of too many uh medical
organizations uh our own included that
would write a white paper a guideline
that did not have extensive data to
support those
guidelines uh and I and so I have a hard
time when I I look at that understanding
where that's coming from other than hey
Two Is Better Than One you know and that
that's kind of the thought process but I
don't see any data there that supports
their argument of
that um that's not to say they're
wrong but I don't I don't know where
that's coming from underst but but you
agree with the general principle
children they more compated more
complicated yeah anesthetically other
than a risk the second thing is we heard
from I think it was Dr lington that made
the statement that in health General
Healthcare um absent the dental setting
that when general anesthesia deep
anesthesia provided there's always two
people in the
room what say that again so I think the
statement that Doc lington and I'm
paraphrasing was that um in medical care
in general not absent Dentistry that
whenever general anesthesia or deep
anesthesia is provided there's an
anesthesiologist in the room as a that's
not always true no so what would so like
er for example ER Physicians routinely
give uh sedatives that don't necessarily
involve another provider what but
question that General aesthetic whether
under or yeah they use ketamine
sorry sorry that's me that's probably my
fault I'm new to this so again I I I I
want to separate moderate low set s
from General anesthe and deep an
anesthesia where we're putting patients
out um and and my understanding and the
doctor staven was that in in the general
in general medicine that's not
appropriate that there's two people an
anesthesiologist and and a provider or
somebody else in the room that when
anesthesia like that is given and and
and being used no I I I would say that
uh they use General anesthetics in the
ER that don't often involve a second
provider and that's uh intomy ketamine
propofol uh so I no I don't think that's
completely true you're also comparing
apples to oranges is not the same thing
you're talking about medical providers
that uh may have a month on anesthesia
rotation so you mentioned the 32 weeks
you know so you're talking about four
and a half weeks of training in
anesthesia like we're like there's
anesthesiology residents that do like
full three or four years there's uh you
know cras and then there's us and beyond
that it's you know you get one month so
yeah no there's no other medical
profession that has that training where
you're running your own operating room
you're intubating people every day you
know like that's there's no one else
okay thank
you see we still have four more people
anfy including a couple doctors it looks
like
so thank you sir cool thank
you uh let's have uh Tom Tommy
Burke and just state your name any
organization you're here
with no you just turned it off at all
there we go better good morning um thank
you all for your time my name is Dr
Tommy Burke I'm an an or I am an oral
and maxal facial surgeon and Private
Practice in nasua and Bedford with both
my dental and medical degrees I'm
serving as the president of the New
Hampshire Society of oral and Maxell
facial surgeons and represent the 52
surgeons across the state who specialize
in safe highquality surgery of the head
face and Jaws on behalf of our society I
commend the board for their efforts but
respectfully urge jail car to Halt
further action on Den 304 the proposed
rule conflicts with legislative intent
fails to serve the public interests and
has a subst Cal economic impact that has
not been fully considered omss are
extensively trained in dentistry
medicine and anesthesia dedicating 8 to
10 years to training dental school
Medical School general surgery and
anesthesiology in order to perform
procedures and administer safe
anesthesia to our patients we love what
we do and the patients that we serve
here's a real world example from my
practice that actually illustrates one
of the case scenarios that was brought
up um and the harm that Den three 4
could cause to Patient Care and families
I received a call on a busy Friday
morning this summer from a parent on
vacation at the lake their young child
was involved in a boning accident
resulting in a fractured upper jaw with
broken and displaced teeth she was
unable to move her mouth or speak as her
teeth were lodged within her upper lip
the patient drove from the Lakes Region
to my office in nasua this is an
emergent situation as her teeth needed
to be removed from her lip and
repositioned with a surgical splint to
save her permanent teeth fix the
fracture and avoid
extractions as you can imagine this is a
case that required sedation to S safely
treat the child the surgery was able to
be completed within hours in a safe
comfortable cost-effective manner for
the patient and her family under the
dental board's language for Den
304 this time-sensitive treatment would
not be possible and most Ms offices in
the state we would not be able to
administer deep sedation without a
separate anesthesia provider or even
moderate sedation with the normal
medications that we typically use for
these cases and we were also trained to
do what about you may ask what about
sending this patient to the emergency
room I have spoken with the director of
the emergency room at my local hospital
St Joseph's the ER is overburdened and
does not have a OMS or dentist on call
at all times as Dr Bean already outlined
the patient would need to be transferred
to another hospital such as Dartmouth or
children's where I've spoken with them
and they are similarly at capacity this
is not even consider the very high
Hospital ER visit costs that may be
incurred if a patient does need to be
taken to the operating room dental
insurance does not typically cover
facility charges where it can cost
patients 10 to 15,000 out of pocket for
an O case this could be as simple as
extracting a single tooth and does not
even include the cost of the surgery
itself I do not feel Den 304 is
adequately recognized this additional
cost on both the system overall but
individual
families itinerant anesthesia providers
are not typically available on a same
day on call basis and are often booked
out for months they can also come with
additional fees where patients can be
required to pay in full prior to
procedures up to $1,000 per hour I would
encourage jail car to make decisions
based on clinical data from the state I
understand there's been a discussion
about data and collection and certainly
that's something that we all are
interested in obtaining so that we can
do the safest thing for our patients and
for our communities however have I want
to ask the question have there been
documented adverse outcomes it's a very
small community as Dr Bean outlined I
feel like we would all be very aware in
a timely manner if there was a large
adverse outcome there's no other state
in the country that has implemented
these policies even in states such as
California North Carolina and Texas
where there have been adverse outcomes
and they've performed studies and they
decided to not do that because there's a
lack of data to support such a sweeping
policy change I cannot imagine it was
the legislator's intent to exclude an
entire subsection of our population
without any
justification no set of rules is perfect
but this is far from it and does not
incorporate our specialty or other
Dental Specialties um input we
respectfully ask you to Halt further
action on Den 304 and direct the board
to redraft the rule in alignment with
public interest legislative intent and
nationally recognized ERS thank you very
much for your time and consideration
[Music]
good morning sorry this I don't normally
do this so lots of emotions around this
issue um I am another uh practicing uh
board certified oral and maxel facial
surgeon in the State uh Amy field um I
work right here in ASA um I've been
licensed to give sedation in the state
for over 25 years um as a female I'm
sought out by a lot of parents and
fellow dentists to treat pediatric
patients as a mother of two one of which
fairly similar to these other stories in
a Boy Scout camp breaks his jaw so we
had to manage him and me being the mom
couldn't manage him myself had to find a
surgeon had to find a hospital had to
end up bringing him down to uh
Massachusetts to treat him because there
was no facilities in the state that we
could manage him he needed uh general
anesthesia um so I'm well aware of the
need for Sedation in our offices and in
our local
hospitals um I have significant concerns
that the den 34 is not in the public
interest and we'll have significant
access to care issues for the kids of
New Hampshire uh the changes in the
rules for anesthesia in office will also
create significant difficulties for our
parents seeking care for their children
not everybody has a car not everybody
has uh you know two parents a lot of
these kids that are on Medicaid have
single parents they have to stop their
job they have to get in a car if they
have one and get these kids to
appropriate
facilities
um they children are a unique subset of
our population as you you all know um
and they are both physically and
psychologically fragile they're all
they're also of a different subset you
know we talked about that 0 to8 age um
needing us needing Pals training to
treat them they are physiologically
different so we as um um oral surgeons
are well aware of the difficulties the
risk and the um ability to treat these
in an office
setting um pediatric dentists and um
oral surgeons we all highly trained to
manage them um and we effectively treat
them on a weekly basis um in my practice
I only have one day a week with two
providers in the office with the rule
changes I can't provide sedation for a
kid under eight and would need to limit
to one day a week for those over a to
sedate them forcing me to either send
them elsewhere or rely on the good
graces of my Lo local hospital um it
usually takes one to two months to
schedule a hospital case unless it's an
emergency um I don't feel that Den 34 is
adequately taking this information into
consideration for the welfare of the
public especially the the kids um we we
heard about dental infections um they
are in children rapid fast and
life-threatening so allowing these kids
to be identified in our office and
treated in a timely manner is
critical
um the only hospitals in New Hampshire
that I know of um that can safely manage
emergency pediatric patients are
Dartmouth and one other at the Sea Coast
my local hospital of St Joe's is not one
of them they don't even have a
Pediatrics Department so when I have to
bring a kid in I have to rely on the
ability to have either an outside
pediatric um pediatrician come in or
make sure that they go home same day
um there's one other point that I wanted
to clarify um if that would be helpful
um just because it says one provider
doesn't mean there's one person in the
room we have three dedicated staff with
each of our pediatric patients one
monitor in one assisting and then the
doctor that's actually performing the
procedure so we're not working in a
vacuum um and our uh staff will not be
allowed to work on those cases until
they've had specific training it's
called Dance Training so that they are
well aware and uh equipped to handle any
of those um emergencies that might
happen in the chair um I'm one of the
few Medicaid providers in the state so I
see a lot of kids m well over 50 uh a
year in this age you know under six to
13 group
um if these rules go into effect
basically I have no idea where I'm going
to send these kids I can't send them all
up to Manchester I can't send them all
up to Dartmouth maybe I can send them
across state lines but that is going to
be extremely expensive and um extremely
um difficult for the parents of the
these kids to to make that happen so
thank you for hearing me out appreciate
your
time oh sorry
good afternoon thank you very much for
your time this morning my n name is Dr
Sarah finny I am the New Hampshire
Medicaid dental
director um I I want to start out by
saying that I fully recognize that this
uh rule change has had to weigh access
versus risk which is not an easy balance
to strike and so I appreciate all the
time and energy that has gone into
getting us to this point
um I also want to comment on you know
prior speakers we need to do better
reporting without a doubt um that's not
a New Hampshire issue that's Nationwide
so I would love to see uh better
reporting come out of this whole um
process while uh my comments are going
to be limited towards Medicaid I am
speaking for the division of Medicaid
services today um these rule changes I
know know were had the best of
intentions to provide more safety for um
our youngest kids being treated but I
think that unfortunately as we have
heard there could be unintended
consequences that are very
negative um I think that without going
over the same information again and
again I absolutely agree with what Dr
field just said um we have an access
issue across this state there is limited
o time for dental cases to be brought
there um and that makes those cases be
pushed out months not days or weeks um
and I think that unfortunately this rule
would make that situation
worse as has already been said children
who already have a dental infection need
to get that focus of in in infection
taken out as soon as possible otherwise
um you risk um much wor infection if not
other uh medical
consequences in state fiscal year 2024
which is July 1st of 2023 to June 30th
of 2024 there were 187 cases of children
under the age of nine that were Sedated
by oral
surgeons in New Hampshire this is you
know Medicaid
data um I have serious concerns if 187
children had to be reappointed in a
different location or with waiting for
um a secondary anesthesia provider to be
available um those children are going to
end up either back at the general
dentist's office if not the emergency
room requiring much more um treatment
and feeling much
worse um so I I just ask you to um keep
in mind that
we are all concerned about weighing risk
versus safety and that's not to be taken
lightly but this bill as it is uh the
rule as it is written currently I think
pushes us more towards risk and we need
to consider this for and and work on
this rule to fine-tune it
again I'm happy to answer
questions so do real quick before going
we're going to get the represent
question did so your opinion is that
this this weighs too heavily on the risk
side and and doesn't give enough thought
to access right thank
you I had the same question for all the
other doctors but I held on to it
because I was looking for somebody with
your particular purview namely how how
many of these cases that we're talking
about are either infection or baseball
bat to the face so so to speak I am
going to be honest with you I do not
have that breakdown in my data you have
any IDE I would say the vast majority
are infection we have very in Medicaid I
have relatively low numbers of jaw
fractures come through on a yearly basis
I'm getting nding from your colleagues
thank
you further questions represent uh thank
you Mr chairman um does your data on
that 187 children show what type of
providers they were seeing were they
largely Oro oral and aop facial surgeons
or all oral
surgeons thank you and so there's none
of the sedation happening with other
providers for children for dental care
there are um I was tasked with looking
at what was happening in oral surgery
offices um I can certainly go back and
provide information because there is
anesthesia being provided at Pediatric D
offices as well um and then I also had
numbers for the amount of moderate
sedation that was done by pediatric
dentists for that same fiscal year that
information I think would be helpful but
the biggest part was those were all all
Doc all providers who were trained in
this who who treated those 187 children
that wouldn't be able to with these
rules correct correct thank you thank
you any further questions see thank you
doctor did you just one yeah of the
again with the reporting of the 187
children were there any adverse effects
did do you already did we already ask
that they are not reported to me um I I
have not and I know I would have heard I
did not get any U reporting on that
thank
you yes see now thank you do thank you
next up is Bindy Hall
good
morning and I first want oh yes
afternoon um I first want to thank you
for your time with this subject matter
because it is very important and it's
really um also as a mother as previously
spoken kind of pulls at some
heartstrings among myself as a pediatric
dentist again my name is Doctor Mindy
Hall and I'm a board certified pediatric
dentist with practice locations in both
Alton and wolfboro New Hampshire I do
serve a large majority of the North
Country in New Hampshire and over 50% of
my practice is
Medicaid I do have statistics for you I
can follow up Dr sarapin did give me
information regarding moderate sedation
and moderate sedation
providers in the past three years
actually
um but in the most recent year pediatric
dentists have provided moderate station
for over 69 patients oral
surgeons have provided moderate station
for eight patients so a total of 77
okay in
2022 pediatric dentists performed over
110 moderate
sedations oral surgeons provided 21 of
the total of 131 claims coming through
the State Medicaid
Department I can testify I have done
many more than that um to follow up I am
here as a public policy advocate for New
Hampshire
also representing the New Hampshire
Academy of pediatric dentistry and the
American Association of pediatric
dentistry I'm here today to
unequivocally oppose the New Hampshire
Board of dental
examiners D de 304 proposed guidelines
specifically as it relates to Pediatric
minimal and moderate
sedation I currently possess an
unrestricted moderate sedation permit
and for the last 17 years I've been
performing moderate station to patients
over the age of two and over my training
at the University of Florida College of
Dentistry was in the use of oral and
nasal intranasal moderate
station I have safely performed over a
thousand moderate stations here in the
state of New Hampshire since
2017 and over the course of my career I
have successfully performed with no
adverse reactions over 3,000 moderate
sedation cases suffice it to say I have
extensive experience in the use of
moderate sedation in the pediatric
dental office
setting I want to clarify that moderate
sedation which is much different than
deep sedation is is defined by the Ada
the American dentals Association as a
drug induced depression of Consciousness
during which patients respond
purposefully to verbal
commands Okay so what this means is that
patients are awake for these procedures
and they have bilateral communication
with the doctor this is clearly very
different from being put to sleep for
deep sedation or IV sedation in general
anesthesia with these proposed
guidelines as are presented in front of
you today the board is inexplicably
attempting to eliminate the ability of a
pediatric dentist to administer oral
moderate sedation to any patient
patients under the age of
n this is at complete variance with the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
American Academy of pediatric dentistry
joint clinical guidelines which have
already been referred to regarding deep
sedation these guidelines do adhere to
the highest safety regimen and
nationally established best
practices let me be very clear no other
state is proposing to restrict pediatric
dentists in This Way New Hampshire would
be the only state in the country to
prohibit pediatric dentists from
utilizing moderate sedation to patients
of any
age to date I have not received any data
or any explanation that would support
making these drastic
changes what the board has done with
these proposed guidelines is combine
permitting guidelines for moderate St
together with deep sedation in general
CIA dentists who strictly perform
moderate sedation such as myself would
be required to apply and re receive a
permit for deep sedation this is not
possible however because we are not
trained in deep
sedation therefore the only practitioner
who could perform sedation on a patient
under age n be it moderate sedation or
deep sedation would be an oral
surgeon oral surgeons mainly focus on
extractions for this age group when
patients are beginning um and
experiencing pain or swelling and
significant infection and oftentimes as
you have heard will require a hospital
setting on the other hand pediatric
dentists can treat a healthy child in
the office with moderate sedation to
resolve the dental issues before things
get out of hand before major swelling
occurs as you've heard from Dr bean and
he had to treat them in the hospital
so the child as you can imagine would
benefit from this
significantly the patients Dental issues
are resolved and they don't need to go
undergo a deeper and more expensive form
of sedation which comes with additional
risks we all have a role to play here in
New Hampshire taking care of New
Hampshire's children and each role
complements the other if you remove one
of the roles it upsets the balance and
starts placing unnecessary stress and
strains on the entire
system removing the option of
modernization limits the pediatric
dentist ability to tailor treatment to
each child's unique needs many General
dentists as well as pediatric dentists
who choose not to perform moderate
station rely on those who do for
patients whose parents prefer a less
invasive option other than IV sedation
or deep sedation without access to
moderate sedation these families may
find themselves needing to seek care out
of state perhaps and leading to
additional costs and logistical
challenges Additionally the requirement
as we've heard a second provider to come
in to provide modernization for me for
my patients would create a huge backlog
of appointments my current weight list
to have another anesthesia come to my
office is three months with the amount
of moderate sedation cases I currently
do this would extend to about a
six-month
weight this delay as you can imagine
will be particularly detrimental in
emergency situations where timely
intervention is
critical of course affordability is
another crucial Factor IV sedation will
cost three to four times more than
moderate sedation and many families
simply can't afford this making moderate
station a more accessible and
cost-effective option for obtaining
necessary dental care when patients
can't afford treatment many will end up
foregoing care for their child I see it
every day in my office and this
continues and allows the dental disease
to progress and pain and suffering then
to
continue I'd like to share with you at a
one of the the November 4th Dental board
meeting I invited a colleague of mine Dr
Sarat vieri a pediatric dentist and also
the chair of the aapd committee on
sedation in anesthesia he gra graciously
traveled from Ohio to accompany me to
the November 4th board meeting at the
meeting he attempted to provide context
and reason with the board regarding the
proposed moderate sedation guidelines he
stated and I quote I would like to
discuss why the aapd is perplexed by and
cannot in good faith support the
proposed amendments to
de34 it is our assessment that this
amendment would result in increased
suffering reduced access delays in care
and dangerous outcomes for the children
of new hampsh
unquote he continued by adding and I
quote despite the proposed regulations
citing a reputable Source the Ada
guidelines New Hampshire's proposed
amendment is not in alignment with these
guidelines the proposed amendment is
applying deep sedation and general
anesthesia educational requirements to
moderate sedation rather then aligning
them with the moderate sedation
educational requirements the way in
which these proposed guidelines are
written is extremely
misleading
unquote he finished by saying and I
quote overall the proposed amendments
make little sense other than to restrict
access for children and to deny
pediatric dentists from practicing an
advanced Behavior guidance technique
that we are well trained to
perform it is critical to note that the
New Hampshire Academy of pediatric
dentistry and the American Academy of
pediatric dentistry leadership is eager
to assist the board in a collaborative
effort to create minimal and moderate
station guidelines that are clear and
understandable and in the Public's best
interest in fact the
aapd is planning to attend a sedation
Summit with other professional
organizations early next year to
finalize a joint moderate sedation model
for States who use who to to use to
guide them and assist them in creating
guidelines appr moderate sedation
guidelines and these guidelines can then
be recognized nationally according to
the accepted standards of care and the
best
practices it would be wise for New
Hampshire to benefit from this
collaborative
effort at this time I would like to
share with
you
two something from two different
families that I have been asked to come
to this meeting to testify their
experiences with their children in my
office um neither of them were able to
attend however I will submit to you in
writing their letters and I would like
to just share an excerpt from each one
of them one of my patients that came to
me recently who is a special special
needs patient his mother was referred to
me after unsuccessful treatment at
another General Dent dental office and
she states quote I am writing to express
my strong support for keeping moderate
station as an available option in
Pediatric Dentistry as aent parent of a
child who has received dental care I
understand the critical role that
sedation plays in ensuring a positive
and safe experience for children
especially for those who may be anxious
fearful or require extensive dental
procedures maintaining moderate station
as a viable option will ensure that all
children regardless of their individual
challenges have access to the dental
care they need in a compassionate and a
supportive environment I urge you to
continue to allow pediatric dentists to
provide this important option for
families like mine this is from a mother
from Chai Chester New
Hampshire second parent from Portsmith
New Hampshire was given the option of IV
sedation for her child she was not
comfortable with this option and she
came to my office for a second opinion
she states I am writing in support of
oral conscious station for children my
daughter recently saw Dr Mindy Hall for
tooth extraction that utilized oral
sedation and the experience was
extremely positive the procedure was
quick and smooth and my daughter handled
it very well oral conscious station is a
much more affordable option compared to
deep sedation additionally it provides
greater flexibility as my daughter was
able to secure an an early appointment
to address her crack tooth this approach
proved to be efficient and effective and
I strongly hope it remains an option for
children given the advantages of oral
conscious I'm deeply concerned about any
efforts to eliminate it as an option for
parents I sincerely hope Financial
motivations are not influencing such
options as I've already previously
mentioned I'm here today representing 43
pediatric dentists in New Hampshire and
over 8,000 pediatric dentists across the
country we're all speaking with an
unmistakable voice reject Den 304 the
use of general anesia and sedation by
dentists and require that the New
Hampshire Board of dental examiners to
go back to the drawing board and
generate minimal and moderate station
permitting and guidelines that are both
independent from Deep sedation in
general anesthesia and comply with
nationally accepted standards and best
practices the children of New Hampshire
deserve nothing less than our best
efforts to really get this right I thank
you for your time and your consideration
and I would like to point out one more
thing regarding the RSA rules of the
dental practice act and what it states
in regarding minimal sedation and I do
not agree that it actually is in line
with these rules and these guidelines I
think there's a conflict and I want to
make sure that I bring that up to your
attention I have submitted an email
which you have in your public testimony
of your 131 Pages starting at page
128 you will will see in there that de
30411 has no age limitation regarding
who can perform minimal sedation on
patients so the age 13 has been
eliminated under the de
30411 so any dentist is going to be able
to now give a child any age
a drug without having permitted so there
really is no regulation in looking over
these
patients according to RSA 317 a12 it
states in there for Pediatric minimal
sedation permitting and training is
required so if nothing else that would
tell you today and make you pause I
would hope that you would really look
and consider that thank you questions
for the
doctor see n thank you do so do actually
I'm just gonna have one clarifying so
again you're here for
for and Tim I'll get you um you're here
for uh the AAP aapd right so um the
American Association of pediatric
dentists right yes so their rule only
governs having two people in a room for
General and deep anesthesia only is that
correct correct but the rule that's
being proposed also includes moderate in
its definition it
does uh Senator mug you thank you Mr
chairman thank you dror for coming
thanks for your testimony I appreciate
it sure um quick question for you of
your your team of lovely ladies at
Lakeside how many of them are Pals or
ACLS certified so for my dental
assistance the requirement for my
um first and secondary dental assistants
to help me in Moder station is that
they're BLS certified which is not
require for them to be pal certified or
ACLS certified so yourself and Dr mccan
are are you both either ACLS or Pal
certified for so I am currently both
because that's what's currently required
yes did you get that training either
through the hospital or through through
docks or DS actually I have a sedation
course that I still attend in Florida
where I used to practice
where I um are able to accommodate and
it's specifically tail tailored for
pediatric dentists which is actually
really helpful thank you yep sen avard
uh yes I'm just I I guess I must have
missed something because I thought we
were only talking about deep sedation
not moderate sedation in the
rules yes I want to clarify I I do think
um Dr Dr Hall yes um makes a good
argument for a lack of authority in in
regards to the minimum sedation I would
need to do more research but I think
that is a valid reason for objection um
I'm also hearing that there's a lot of
legislative intent question here so
there that would be another reason for
objection further questions from the
represent land um thank you I just
wanted to clarify that with the rules as
written um it um soorry in the law it
says that there may also be um the Min
moderate sedation that that can be a
separate one for moderate sedation
separate from the deep sedation and
without offering a moderate sedation
only you're not able to provide the
current care that you provide for your
patients because you wouldn't qualify
for the Deep sedation corre correct
because the current moderate sedation
permit has age restrictions to it again
over nine thank you great further
comments seeing n thank you very much
you're
welcome yes
I I do want to let there's one person
who wants to speak in support I think it
was um and I haven't I haven't gotten to
him yet so I'd like to at least have one
person who wants to speak in support
give their point of view because we've
heard from the doctors against so uh is
Dwayne
here and then if someone wants to make a
motion hey
guys introduce yourself sir thank you
committee and chair my name is Dr Dwayne
TBO I'm a nurse anesthesiologist that
provides anesthesia to pediatric and
adult patients in dental offices
throughout the state of New
Hampshire one of the big concerns that I
see this board and the board of
dentistry struggle with is the question
of access to
care one of the questions that I would
like to be asked is if access to care is
such an
issue the most vulnerable population
that we have here in this state are the
children that are on
Medicaid I would ask how many oral
surgeons take Medicaid or accept
Medicaid in their
office I do for all my
patients my understanding there's only a
handful so when they talk to you about
access to care the issue being is
they're not seeing those
patients I would ask Dr Finny she may
have a better answer than I do but my
understanding is there's only a handful
I don't know if she has a number but
with my research there was only handful
she might be able to get us a better
number the other issue to access to care
they talk about the child that quote
gets the baseball bat to the face or
falls off the um swing set and needs
immediate
care they're saying that
because they wouldn't have access to
care because there isn't an anesthesia
provider that could perform the
anesthesia and this another one to that
would perform the surgical
procedure in most of the offices here in
New Hampshire a good portion of them
there are more than one oral surgeon in
that office oral surgeon are highly
trained professionals to provide
anesthesia that's not in question their
education is not in question here at all
they are trained they are highly trained
the question is when you have an Emer
is it better to have a separate provider
providing that anesthesia for that
8-year-old and under or is it better to
have
one that's the question you have to ask
yourself and the gold standard is what
the hospital the surgery center why
should it be any different going into a
dental office that gold standard is two
separate
providers there's no reason that that
child that falls off the swing set falls
off and or gets the baseball bat to the
face cannot be sent to an oral surgeon's
office that Pro that has two oral
surgeons there one can provide the
anesthesia and one can provide the
surgical procedure why doesn't this
happen again no one wants to talk about
it but it might be Financial just like
the reason that there's no Medicaid
patients being taken care of or there's
a lack thereof I should
say so there's no reason these patients
can't receive care and you have to think
about the degree of the
emergency I work with surgeons and in
the operating room where everything's an
emergency because they want to get their
case in is this an emergency that has to
be done right this
moment or is this emergency that can
wait two hours or four hours because
those cases could be done in the dental
office it's the ones that are emergent
so we have to define the definition of
what's emergent and what isn't
emergent those kids that are emergent
should be going to the hospital no doubt
about
it those that are less emergent could be
seen later that day or maybe even the
following day there was a a scenario
that was laid out where the patient
stayed in the hospital for four or five
days why why wasn't that tooth taken out
beforehand the other thing is you're
talking about access to care about how
they say there is no oral surgery cover
in these covering in these hospitals why
is that is it because the oral surgeons
don't take call so are we construing
safety and access to
care with the fact that it's an access
to care issue
because we're not seeing these
vulnerable populations because of
financial reasons we need to weigh that
into this decision- making of This of
whether or not the board of Dentistry
has weighed the data weighed the
information and tried to come up with
the best safest compromise for these
children I would say that safety trumps
anything access to care can be addressed
and
fixed but there is no access to care
issue if people simply do a few extra
things take call see the Medicaid
patients
you know there was also a scenario where
chairman asked is there any other place
in medicine where deep sedation and
general
anesthesia is done by a single
provider respectfully
no that ER scenario you were given was
probably moderate or minimal sedation
though the anesthetic medications could
be used to deepen that anesthetic to
create a deep sedation in general anesth
I and my background is 18 years working
in an emergency room providing care as
an ER nurse a charge nurse before I went
to Anesthesia school and I
wholeheartedly deny the fact that we
gave deep sedation general
anesthesia to fix a cut to fix a broken
finger we gave moderate station and if
we needed to and the person needed they
went to the o or o staff and anesthesia
staff came down to do do the actual deep
sedation general anesthesia that ER
physician did not do that on their
own they also talked about their staff
being highly
trained but they won't tell you what
that training is that the oral surgeons
uh assistants have they say it's highly
trained what the reality is and it's
documented that they take a 36-hour home
study
course and that's their an athesia
training that's going to replace me or
an oral surgeon or a dental
anesthesiologist with a doctorate
degree I'm sorry prior to most of these
people actually going into the dental
Community they were tellers at Banks
they were doing other things in the
community they they don't even have
a there's not a standard of Education
out there for these dental assistants
but we'll pull a bank true story a bank
teller educate them into the the the the
oral surgeon's office 5 Weeks Later have
them turn around and take a 36 home
study course and now they can monitor a
pediatric patient under
anesthesia where is the safety where is
the safety but you're not hearing these
things because they glaze over them they
actually don't tell you the the the
nitty-gritty and being the not being the
experts you're relying on their expert
testimony to tell you exactly what goes
down in those offices and I think we're
missing some of those
facts I will say this that if there are
187 Medicaid patients per Dr Finny being
seen by Oral Surgeons I can tell you
that my
practice sees almost that many in of
itself never mind taking that 8
187 um Medicaid patients and dispersing
them over 50 providers my practice has
three we see over 100 patients a year so
how does that equate the issue isn't the
187 the issue isn't even how I see 100
the issue is the fact that they don't
see those patients because they don't
take the
insurance now a little bit off topic
today but there was a article in the
paper recently that came across the wire
a 17-year-old died in a oral surgeon's
office taking an extraction for one
third Moler under deep sedation general
anesthesia 17 year-old larger Airway
much more respiratory Reserve much more
easier to take care of than a 8-year-old
pediatric
patient these people are dying in these
offices and the reality is is they're
not being reported because when the
families settle in court there's an NDA
done they're not allowed to talk about
it so again we're running into the fact
that we don't have accurate data for how
many this is happening to these are just
deaths we're not talking about the
neurological impairment for from being
hypoxic for so long we're not talking
about any of these other things and
whether anybody in this room wants to
admit it or even knows it there have
been deaths here in New Hampshire
under oral surgery in an oral surgeon's
office by an
adult now we're talking about pediatric
patients here I think the board has
struck a very very very good compromise
and I whole support their deep sedation
and general anesthesia stance you had an
oral surgeon here testifying on behalf
of it this oral surgeon was integral in
researching the data using the
information and having gone forth to the
board with
recommendations and other information
that the board
considered closing is the borders
Dentistry has weighed the access to care
versus the cost and I don't want to be
the one sitting
here that has a six-year-old or an
eight-year-old ding a dental office and
we could have done something about
it access to care will come
safety I don't want that on my
conscience I do I do anesthesia every
day for Pediatric patients throughout
the
week I'm a separate provider and I'm not
saying everybody has to have a separate
provider for moderate sedation or even
minimal sedation but when you do deep
sedation and general anesthesia on a
pediatric patient there is there is no
room for error and there
staff 36- hour home study course versus
having two separate doctorally prepared
providers in the room the gold standard
is the hospital I don't I don't know
what else to say I'll take any questions
thank you for your time one question sen
aart just uh getting back to the
moderate sedation do these new proposed
rules affect the moderate U sedation for
Aid and under
yes um thank you and thank you for
bringing a Viewpoint that wasn't
expressed by as many other people um you
did reference them and their specific um
benefits from the rules I just would
like to clarify you're you're a nurses
nesst yes and um so with that then these
there would be more procedures that are
required to be attended by people with
the same lcer as you
correct could you clarify that so I can
answer you very more specific because I
think I might be misunderstanding you I
I you had you had made statement saying
that there were there there was a
financial interest from people people
who did not want to add another provider
to the treatment of of these patients
and you are part of that group who would
be required I just wanted to clarify I'm
not accusing you of bias I just want to
highlight that that there's multiple
sides to an issue yes and and to answer
your question now I understand where
you're going so when someone has
provided anesthesia in a dental office
there are two bills there's an
anesthesia Bill and there's a surgical
bill right so when one provider provides
that service they double dip they get
both anesthesia and the surgical
procedure when I come in and provide the
same
anesthesia I get the anesthesia fee the
dentist gets the the surgical fee for
instance Medicaid I don't get paid
anymore than anybody else when I see
that Medicaid patient in that dental
office no more for anesthesia than any
oral surgeon would any Dental
anesthesiologist would or any physician
anesthesiologist would we get paid the
same the difference is both of those
fees the surgery and the anesthesia
field is not going to one person it
would be going to two separate people
there is no additional cost let me
underline that no additional
cost for that scenario for that Medicaid
patient thank you I I could say there's
no reason to say anymore I'm just
where're else at it looks like there's
no more questions way I'm going to let
uh it looks like you want to speak one
more time real quick I'm going to let
her from Medicaid because because I
think she had some might answer some
question thank you for your time thank
you I just want to clarify something
that's very important some of the
numbers that um Dwayne was telling you
that 187 patients that I said to you
those are specifically children under
the age of nine who had deep sedation
during fiscal year 2024 that is not
the total of
Medicaid covered children who were
treated by oral surgeons in a year trust
me it is thousands and thousands more
than that so I ju I just want you to
understand I was speaking specifically
about the number of children who had
deep sedation in one fiscal
year okay I just have one clarification
item on what you were talking about so
the comment was made of the number of
oral surgeons in the State and the
number that take Medicaid and the and
the Delta between those two do you have
any idea what that looks like I I
honestly cannot give you a number
without looking at my current um list uh
but it is more than a handful and um we
also have you know two we have two
different benefits now there is one for
children one for adults and we are
actively recruiting to increase both of
those networks but they are much more
robust today than they were five years
ago thank you anything else see I
represent representative
M thank you Mr chair I move to
preliminarily object to this rule on the
grounds that doesn't meet the public
interest for not properly well among
other things not properly addressing the
distinction between moderate and deep
sedation and other issues brought up by
the public testimony
also that it's missing a leg a an age
limit in
20411 which is required by Statute
second M Mr chair I'm just to clarify
for I'm sorry go ahead so we get the
record right so representative Maguire
made a motion to preliminary object and
it was second in by representative was a
tie sorry I just heard it from over
there so so Mr chair the preliminary
objection what happens from there so the
preliminary objection I actually why
have staff answer that so preliminary
objection they'll go back to the agency
and they'll have a chance to
understanding look at our objection and
maybe redesign the uh rule right so
they'll come back to us the revised rule
thank you 45 days yes they have 45 days
to respond and then after that 45 days
jail car will have 50 days both
deadlines can be waved and
extended any further discussion on
preliminary objection jection uh thank
you uh Mr chairman and uh member I I
found um several areas where it did see
in the legislative intent where I saw
the language was different than the
rules um the first being in 12 ah1 the
third sentence permits that exemption
for oral and maxial surgeons um that's
permitted and it's not allowed and if
you look at the public interest and the
lack of access I thought that that
specific part of the law might make
sense to call out um then also in 12 ad
it allows for both General deep moderate
permits or moderate permits but I don't
see a moderate permit that's permitted
for Pediatric patients and when you
combine that with the Authority Under 12
ah that provides for the additional
requirements for children under 13 for
General and deep sedation it doesn't
provide for that differentiation for
moderate sedation for those pediatric
patients um so I see that as a potential
legislative intent that's conflicting um
with with how the rules were drafted
since they don't allow a moderate permit
for all ages um and then lastly um it
was mentioned that in 12cc there
requires a permit for met minimal
sedation and that's not in rules that
was brought up by somebody testifying
but I I didn't have a chance to look at
that section so I'm just sort of tossing
that
out did you get all
that any further discussion so the
motion on on table is uh does Maguire
want to amend her
objection to include what represented
okay thank you for
that any further discussion seeing the
motion is to preliminary object based on
the out guidelines that were outlined
all those in favor say I I all those
opposed nay no the eyes have it and
there's a preliminary objection the
agency can come back and uh address
those not finishes the board of
Industry all right so why don't we take
like a 10minute break let people get up
stretch their legs use the restroom that
kind of thing we'll be back here at 1:10
based on that
clock
e
e e
at your you do not you are not required
because we've already had testimony
twice
so well you could if you want
to you don't want we're going to get and
open up uh and come back to jail car and
I am yeah so we come back to order um
we're going to move on to objection
responses Solid Waste programs landfill
requirements rule o
2474 and um we'll start with the staff
and then we'll go to the agency if you
guys want to come up you can get ready
all right so um the objection response
was returned from the agent genc and no
changes were made to the RO text I have
no substantive comments on the RO text
the dees did
um try to address the reasons for
objection including um the dees states
that the rules were more projective than
the current rules and that um
they um responded to public comment and
considered public comment that's
evidenced by their 26 page summary of
comment ments and exhibit two in the
packet that has the spreadsheet of all
comments and um they stated that there
were no um Communications with
stakeholders outside of the ruem
process and I think that um eliminates
the the bases for objections that that
were
raised and so I have no more further com
comments
great introduce yourself guys good
afternoon I'm assistant Commissioner
Adam kpo at the Department of
Environmental Services and I here with
me uh Mike whimet with the waste
management division um so I'll just give
a quick intro and I'll hand it over to
to Mike but um you know we we received a
preliminary objection the last time we
were at JL car um we feel that we have
responded to the reasons for the
objection there were three reasons uh um
you know and we we believe that these
rules are are much more protective than
the current existing
rules um and beyond that I you know the
we believe that we also uh provided
plenty of opportunity for public comment
through the process uh we I would argue
we went above and beyond uh the required
uh process for public comment when
creating rules and doing rul making uh
under five 41A and uh so I think th
those two points really um encapsulate
many of many of the reasons that that
went into doing a preliminary objection
so I'll I'll hand it over to Mike to
kind of go into more detail uh but one
of the other things I would I would like
to add is that these rules are more
protective in 27 27 different areas and
in no case are less protective than to
Public Health and the environment than
the current existing rules and so Mike I
don't know if you want to go into that
or um representative
Maguire yes thank you based on that
response I would like to move to approve
the rule
second okay it's I speak on speak it's
been moved by representative Maguire and
seconded by Senator avard um and you may
speak to your motion thank you Mr chair
I want to approve the rule rule which is
more protective than the 10 plus year
old rules we have currently effect in
effect because we need
to settle it and go with this improved
level of protection they are not perfect
but most of the issues we have heard
from and we've had voluminous public
testimony appear to be based more on the
policy
for landfills than on the specifics of
the rules and I know there are more than
three bills coming in this year that
address the policy of
landfills
and I would like to have a better
Baseline in our rule in the rules before
we settle the issue of the policy be any
changes to the
policy and because if any of those bills
pass and change the requirements the
rules will have to be updated to
incorporate those
changes and I would that that's my major
purpose is to separate the policy
discussion which
is important from the rules discussion
and jel car is not a policy committee we
can only go by what's currently in the
laws so I'm that's why I moved to
approve the the
rule any comments any comments from
anybody else represent
Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman so I will be opposing the
motion uh because uh I I feel that the
uh statement that the um response of the
agency uh to the fact that these rules
are better than the existing rules
proposed rules are better than the
existing rules uh is uh is um almost
disrespectful to the uh amount of
opposition that the these rules have
received from the public um and the fact
that they may be better in a whole
series of ways does not mean that better
is
good uh better is not a sufficient
response um these rules are not uh
protect Ive enough uh and the fact that
they may be better than the existing
rules is is is is very weak in my
opinion uh and uh but I I I want to have
an opportunity for uh the the argument
to be made with regard to a number of
other aspects um of uh the opposition
that we've SE that we have heard and
seen um and but also in with with regard
to the objection bases that
representative Leon's motion uh was
based on and uh that this committee
voted unanimously in support of so I I
think the the the the um agencies uh
categorical uh defense of their response
or non-response as the case may be uh
needs to be further explored and we need
to
proceed open to further disc question
and
comment representative Leon uh thank you
Mr chairman um looking at this you know
it's a it's a challenging situation to
be in because I don't think that the
rules that are in there as protective as
they should be but I've been trying to
look and see where this doesn't meet
what the statutory guidelines are I'm
trying to see where there is something
that is a role for jel card to say this
because if we look to the the public
benefit we look to these a lot of those
issues about what um environmental
policy should be are settled in the
legislature and policy committees um and
I'm really looking forward to the
discussion on it because I think people
are becoming a lot more educated on this
issue um and as much as I would like to
do something here just because you know
I want to protect the the water and the
soil and and whatnot we also need to
look at what the role is of Jael car and
um if we overstep things here we're
going to set out everything out of whack
as well for every other rule that comes
in front of us so even though we may
personally feel that we want want to do
something we need to act in our role um
as Jael car not as an advocate and not
uh trying to push policy in this
committee further
discussion so I I am going to make the
same statement as as uh representative
Leon understanding this is not a policy
committee the question is as the law was
passed and the rules were drafted based
on the law was passed did they meet the
conditions and terms of the law that was
passed and there's been no objection to
that everyone thinks that it meets the
minimum requirement of the law um which
is one of the criteria for J car's
objection so um the secondary purpose
was again um the the declared intent of
whether or not it protects the natural
environment everything else it's clear
that these rules while may not go as far
as some want that's a policy decision
not a discussion of of for this body um
that's a discussion for the agriculture
environment committee and and the energy
environment committee uh in the house
and the Senate um so from the agency
response and from their objection
response it's clear that again there are
multiple areas where these new rules are
uh more restrictive than the current
rules which go further to protect our
environment protect our water and
protect everything El protect uh the New
Hampshire's Beauty and so um again going
beyond that is not again individual
members here may think it doesn't go far
enough but that's what the purposes of
bills are for is for you to write a bill
and and you can push it further if you
think they didn't go far enough so um
with that if there's no further comment
I'm going to move to a vote and we'll do
this by
a thank you for the question so because
there was a motion made the after a
motion is made public testimony is
generally not accepted in any public
Committee in the legislature um it
becomes a discussion on the on the
motion in and of itself uh is what
happens amongst the members of the
committee so because the representative
Maguire chose to make a motion and it
was seconded by representative avard
that ended uh ended discussion um
amongst a a public body and the agency
and move strictly to a discussion
amongst the
legislature all right that being said is
there any further discussion so we're
going to do this by a show of hands so
we get call it's been asked to have a
roll call we don't have a clerk and so
Doug that usually Falls to
you so do roll call of the sitting
members and a reminder of the sitting
members we have all of the
Senators and uh and with senat avard
being uh sat as an alternate um and then
all of the house members are
present I'll make easy boy I'll do it
all right um we'll start with uh
representative
Schmidt
no representative Lynn
yes representive
Lon
yes representive Gro
yes represent Maguire
yes Senator avard
yes Senator Ward
yes Senator long
yes Senator inis yes and the chair votes
yes so the vote is 9 to one to approve
the rules as uh
presented all right I'm g go back to the
agenda
all right so next item of business is um
is with uh Doug we'll turn it over to
you for the last item of business number
five under other business we have final
proposal cover sheet report
implementation of expired rules and the
filing contained blah blah blah as well
as setting our meeting dates so all
right let's we I I guess we'll just
start right at the top uh the first
thing in front of you is the cover sheet
for the final proposal there was
legislation last session that made
changes to 541 or yes 541a that's going
to require reports of implementation of
expired rules uh we're requesting that
we add question 14 to our cover sheet so
that if the form isn't required the
agency can just check Na and if it is
required it's something we know to look
at and review um we're still going to be
doing that review but it's just going to
make it easier in the first instance
so does this require action and a vote
correct okay so uh I move we allow for
uh the adoption of the final proposal
cover sheet second I'm sorry who said
second I did all right move by set L
second by representative Lynn is there
any further
discussion seeing none all those in
favor say I I all oppos n the eyes have
it and it's done the next up is our
meeting G
meeting dat so there is one there is one
minor request so this is a very
interesting thing it's it's a bizarre
request but the um bar midyear meeting
is actually on Friday February
21st and in order for us to attend we
could not be a jail car that day so we
were simply going to ask if we could
move that meeting to Thursday February
20th but I do understand it is the week
before the recess which is also a very
busy
week so but I thought thought we'd make
the ask so let me so what so the
question is again the the Friday the
21st of February um J car the staff has
a meeting that they need to attend so
they couldn't be able to be here for
that that we clarify would like to
attend we don't need to be nobody will
miss us and so that conflicts with our
meeting date so they're wanting to move
it back but the problem with moving it
back would be that there's probably a
high likelihood we're going to be
meeting on the 20th on Thursday
um and so I'm open to other discussion
or other ideas on that if we have any
mire I'd like to say it's a very high
probability the house at least will be
meeting that Thursday right um You
gentlemen maybe and the Senators may be
more flexible than we are but we're
going to be meeting the 20th so I I
can't support that we can try to to make
it a very abbreviated agenda though yeah
let's we'll work on toward we'll work
towards
that um I move that we adopt the
tentative meeting schedule second it's
been moved and second to adopt the
meeting schedule as written and
presented any further discussion hearing
none all those in favor say I I all
oppos nay guys have it who was the
second
oh last up is an emergency rule that was
put in on the voluntary registry for
Recovery houses and Doug is going to
speak to that for us because the AGC had
had to believe so this was an emergency
rule that was actually on the agenda
last month and got pushed forward I do
want to lead with I don't think there's
any ground for objection essentially the
statute says that you have to use New
Hampshire car Nar standards uh or
something similar the current rule
specifically calls out the New Hampshire
Corps and so under the current rules we
wouldn't be able to do what we need to
do in the state and there's also threat
of litigation because those rules are uh
copyrighted so basically the department
is changing the rule to adjust so that
the agency selected under an RFP can
proceed have they've been selected and
then the department is going to file
rules in January to make that a formal
Thing official regular rule meeting so
if members know agencies are allowed to
file emergency rules for basically two
reasons fiscal and public health um and
so if there's a fiscal impact of
something or a public health impact of
something need to get a rule in place
right now and avoid Ru making they're
allowed to put a a temporary rule in but
as part of that process emergency rule
they must then open Ru making to adopt
or deal with that rule so and that's
what and so we would have an we if if we
didn't think that it was a public health
issue which or even a financial issue
with a lawsuit pending and the
possibility of of not meeting the
requirements of that we have recovery
houses so arguably you have both cases
so we have both cases I think in this
case for the agency to make an emergency
rule so there would be no reason for us
to
object um yes can you just tell us the
procedure like how long they have to to
submit new
rules and when we'd have to act on them
so the emergency rule would be in effect
for 180
days and then if that were just set to
expire the regular rule would just take
its place but the department plans on
enter regular R making before that
happens the emergency rule cannot be
removed
right anything else to come before the
committee I then j a motion to adjourn
second a second all those in favor say I
I just pick any two senators they all
said yes to both
so
leadership for